Autonomous and customized
pre-launch
testing in the
Google Play
Console
>> RICHARD GAYWOOD: Hello.
I'm here to to talk about
pre-launch report.
>> JUSTIN BROUGHTON: I'm
Justin.
Manager of the Firebase Test
Lab.  Thank you for those that
made it at
this rather unGodunGodlyarea.
I'm sure that wordy title didn't
help.
Did we really use the word
autonomous?
Today we here to talk about
intelligence
app and game testing that
requires mercifully little work
on your part, and
it's available on both the play
console and in Firebase Test
Lab.  Both products have massive
increased their offering, and
we're here to tell you about
what's in one, what's in the
other, and what's in both.
We'll tell you our story in the
context of an app.
Testing is a pain, but as you've
probably heard multiple times
this week, it's really
important.
So as much as possible, we want
to take Google's expertise and
resources
and make it our pain and not
yours.
>> JUSTIN BROUGHTON: Let's
start with the pre-launch
report.  This is an automated
scan of your app that aims an
early warning of quality problem
before your users see them.
It's a free service, and it
aapplies
automatically to every alpha or
beta tracks or the new open and
closed testing tracks.
We take APKs that you pass to
Google Play and install them on
about ten devices.  These
devices span a range.  There are
high-end devices like the
pixel 2 and down to low-end
devices like the Samsung Galaxy.
One it's installed we start the
special robocrawler process.
It exs  explores your app like a
user would.  This takes MRAPS on
physical infrastructure, which
is part of a larger farm with
thousands of different
dozens and a large diversity of
hardware and operating systems.
Your fellow developers have told
us they take pre-launch report
very seriously.
In a recent survey, 86% said
that they consider pre-launch
report results to be important
or very important when they
consider whether it's time to
launch a new app into
production.
When developers have ignored or
recommendations and launched in
something we found problems, our
data says about 75% of the time
the problems that we found in
pre-launch report were later
seen by real users.  Those users
got a poor experience.  They may
have left bad reviews.  They may
have left bad ratings.  They
have maze have chose not to
spend money in the app and maybe
uninstalled the app.
Furthermore, pre-launch report
test results are used internally
within play
with a factor when decides how
to feature it rank in the app
store.  We have looked at a
million appears
and if we're not crawling yours,
we'd really like to be doing
that.
As you probably guessed what
from what I guessed, pre-launch
report is good at finding
crashes.  When we find a crash
in your app while we test it, we
give you a lot of information,
stack traces, log caps and
things like that.  Everything to
debug the crash and fix it.  We
don't just do crashes.
We also take screenshots and
capture a video of the crawl on
each device so that you can look
for UX issues in different
languages.  In October we added
performance data.  This is
network, memory and CPU metrics
so that you can look for
performance issues in your app.
So that's what my team does, the
play relaunch report.  What
about your team, Justin?
>> JUSTIN BROUGHTON: So my
teamworks on Firebase Test Lab.
So Firebase Test Lab is a
separate solution that is part
of the suite of products under
the Firebase umbrella.
It uses the same technology as
the pre-launch report including
the larger device farm that
Richard mentioned.
It offers many of the same
features.
It also integrates with a number
of
different tools like Android
studio, FastLane, G cloud SDK
and the Firebase
console allowing developers to
test
their apps and games at all
stages of the application life
cycle across a
wider array of devices giving
you more comprehensive test
results.
So let's talk about an app.
This is fitness bud.
Now, while fitness bud is not a
real application, it does
illustrate real-world problems.
Problems we know that you all
have.
Fitness bud is a social fitness
tracking application built by,
let's say, a small company FB
Solutions.
Fitness Bud allows you to log in
with a Google account or custom
account,
create an online fitness avatar,
invite fitness buddies with whom
to train, and even join a local
gym.
Richard and I are going to take
you through how FB Solutions
makes use of
the many new tools at their
disposal to
develop, test and release their
soon-to-be wildly successful
application.
>> RICHARD GAYWOOD: Thanks,
Justin.
Like my wife reminds me, my body
shape is best described as a
potato on legs,
so I need fitness bud to be
very, very good.
>> JUSTIN BROUGHTON: How many
have spouses like -- no.  Sorry.
How many of you have way more
time than you know what to do
with and can fix every last
problem in your app?  Nobody?
>> RICHARD GAYWOOD: Neither do
we.  With all the signals
pre-launch report makes
available to you, it can be hard
to prioritize to SDIEZ which
issue is the most urge the to
fix.  Starting this week, we
launched a new page which
digests all of the issues we
found into a single launch
recommendation as you can see
here.  This shows up the at the
top of our new overview tab.
The overview tab displays all
the issues
that pre-launch report found
prioritized by severity.
It makes it easy forfeitness bud
to
see at a glance if this new ADK
is ready
for users or not.
>> JUSTIN BROUGHTON: Test lab's
intelligent crawler does a great
job of
crawling the Android framework
part of fitness bud.
Fitness bud uses OpenGL for an
online fitness avatar creation
part.
Previously the pre-launch report
couldn't Tess  tests and appears
in OpenGL, but no it can.  If
you're a game developer, you can
write what are called demo
loops.
Demo loops are an automated
journey through your app.  They
can focus on a particular level
or a particular game character.
Demo loops are a great way --
they are an intent filter that
is declared in your manifest.
They're not normally crawled as
part of the normal running of
the application, but our test
infrastructure will detect them
and run them.
Demo loop's launch year in
Firebase Test Lab.
>> RICHARD GAYWOOD: Starting
this week, demo loops are
available in pre-launch report
as well.  If you choose to add a
demo loop to your app, when we
take your app through pre-launch
report, rather than the usual
robocrawler, we run the demo
loop and output.  We look for
crashes and most importantly
give you performance traces
so you can use demo loops for
accurate benchmarking on our
range of devices.
If you don't use a demo loop, we
have another new feature called
monkey actions.
When we defect an OpenGL part of
the app, we fall to random input
so we get some crawling for you.
Fitness bud really cares about
keeping data safe and secure, so
fitness bud requires customer
log in or log in with Google.
>> JUSTIN BROUGHTON: And if you
use Firebase or both of these
are supported.
>> RICHARD GAYWOOD: As I said
before I was so rudely
interrupted by a message
from our sponsors, pre-launch
report uses an auto log in
feature.  As we test an app,
when we see a sign in with
Google button, we will use it
and we automatically have a
Google account on the device
ready to be signed in.
Applications that don't use log
in with Google can choose to
configure pre-launch report with
a user name or e-mail address
and a password that we will
again use to get past the log in
screen when we see it.
Next, let's talk about deep
links.  Deep links are way to
invoke functionality WRN your
app that bypasses the normal
entry flow.  For example, a user
might start off searching the
web but should be shown those
search results within the app.
Two
>> JUSTIN BROUGHTON: How many
have deep links in your apps?
Wow.  Yeah.  How many test those
deep links at every release of
the app?  One, two?  Nice.
>> RICHARD GAYWOOD: We salute
you.  So fitness bud had this
problem.  They used deep links
to encourage users to sign up to
local gyms.
The user receives a Firebase
notification alerting them to a
special offer.
They click the link and are
taken
straight to fitness bud's gym
signup screen.  This is an
important flow for them, because
money changes hands.
Launching this week, pre-launch
report will test up to three
deep links.  You can configure
it and add the deep links.  We
crawl for the five minutes, and
at the end of the crawl we close
the app and visit each deep link
in turn.  As we visit each deep
link, we crawl for a further 30
seconds.
>> JUSTIN BROUGHTON: So fitness
bud and you can make sure that
users who follow deep links can
have the same great experience.
So as we have seen from the
million-plus
apps that the crawler has
tested, sometimes crucial parts
of an application are only
reached through
some complicated flow like
fitness bud's gym signup form.
It turns out that automated
crawlers
and even some humans aren't that
good at
entering the correct text to
bypass this form.
>> RICHARD GAYWOOD: This is
where roboscripts come in.  It
provides guidance to the crawler
to get past a complicated part
of the app.
They take the form of a short,
scripted sequence of actions
recorded as a Json file.
You can record it using a tool
with
Android studio with the app
running locally you record taps
and swipes.  You up load this to
pre-launch report or Firebase
script lab.
The it guides of early part of
the call to get the app into
some state that you think is
interesting to test.
Once it's completed, the
roboscript starts to crawl
normally.
>> JUSTIN BROUGHTON: Row Bo
Bowe scripts are useful for
crawling forms.
They can also be used to guide
the
crawler past any part that it
finds tricky to navigate.
>> RICHARD GAYWOOD: Usability
and accessibility are really
important to your app.  If you
make your touch targets too
small, you might have a result
like this.
Not one of your better days at
the gym, Justin?
Does that happen to a lot?
>> JUSTIN BROUGHTON: Actually,
no, but
I have a persistent fear of
treadmills.  I haven't been on
one since --
>> RICHARD GAYWOOD: I think
that's probably why.  In the
next few weeks we add an
intelligent crawler to help
uncover usability issues like
that tiny button Justin was
trying to click there.  All
jokes aside, though, small touch
targets are a problem for a wide
range of users including users
using your app
on the go when handed or users
with dexterity impairments.
Legible text is extremely
important, so we will warn you
when text is too small or we
will warn you when the contrast
is too low.
Some visually impaired used rely
heavily
on talk back, so we will also
tell you when talk back
voice-over annotations are
missing or confusing.
>> JUSTIN BROUGHTON: And as you
can tell that infamous button
was trying to click is included
in the usability
results, and it's got a big red
box around it.
Thankfully it's marked as should
fix.
>> RICHARD GAYWOOD: So after a
full
sprint of bug fixing, fitness
bud
uploads a fresh ADK to the
console.  As you can see here,
there are no longer any serious
issues detected.  They can now
push this APK into the
production channel confident the
users receive a good experience.
>> JUSTIN BROUGHTON: So we hope
that you, too, can adopt the
pre-launch report as part of
your decision to launch.
>> RICHARD GAYWOOD: That's what
you get in pre-launch report
available for free
to everyone who publishes AKPs
to the alpha or bait take
channels but now call open and
closed tests tracks.  You can
find it in the Google Play
Console Google Play Console and
managed releases.
>> JUSTIN BROUGHTON: Thank you,
Richard.
>> RICHARD GAYWOOD: You're
welcome.
>> JUSTIN BROUGHTON: As
developers we know that the
earlier we catch problems, the
easier they are to fix.
So if you're a conscientious
developer
or like to save money, you want
to catch problems as quickly as
possible.
This is where Firebase Test Lab
comes in.
Now, many of us, myself
included, have
discussed ad nauseam about the
importance of creating automated
tests
for every part of your
application and to run those
tests continuously to prevent
regressions.  This is honestly
the most important thing you can
do to improve the quality of
your applications.
Writing tests is hard.  That's
why when I ask in gatherings
like this how many of you have
automated
tests that cover every part of
your application, way too few of
you put up your hands.
So I gave up nagging a while
ago, and
we at Google have put a lot of
focus
into creating -- creating tests
for apps and games without
actually having to write those
tests.
Earlier we saw the automated
crawler, which is part of
Firebase Test Lab as
what we call a robotest.  We can
do much more.
Let's look at how we can create
tests for all the different
parts of fitness bud.
So one of the first things that
I as a
user of fitness bud wants to do
is create my fitness avatar,
which
involving uploading my photo and
from that photo --
there it is -- the app actually
creates a caricature of me.
That seems to have emphasized
all my worst flaws.
It then allows me to choose a
focused activity.
Weight training.
>> RICHARD GAYWOOD: Is that
really you up there, Justin?
>> JUSTIN BROUGHTON: It appears
that my ears are not my worst
flaw.  Vanity is.
Then I get to guide my
excessively buffed avatar around
the various gym
activities with all my equally
unrealistic fitness buddies.
Now all this avatar stuff is
written
in OpenGL.  For a more immersive
and fun experience for the user.
Previouslily it's been hard to
test apps
and games which use OpenGL, but
over the last year, we at Google
have introduced
a couple of ways in which you
can now do this more easily.
>> RICHARD GAYWOOD: We
introduced at I/O last year the
concept of demo loops that we
discussed earlier, and
pre-launch report now runs demo
loops in your apps and games if
you choose to include them.
>> JUSTIN BROUGHTON: Fitness
bud can construct demo loops for
all this avatar stuff by simply
recording and replaying their
OpenGL commands.
And then during testing they can
verify that they don't see
crashes or performance issues.
Now, fitness bud can run these
demo
loops locally on their devices
using an app we created that's
freely available, but more
importantly, they can run those
demo loops in Firebase Test Lab
across a
wide array of devices.
Secondly, we announced at the
games developer conference
earlier on this
year a collaboration with net
ease to
create tests for games that run
in Firebase Test Lab.  Net ease
is one of the largest games
development companies in China,
and as
part of this collaboration, they
OpenSourced their test
environment, air test, along
with a couple of frameworks
that they use internally for
developing testing for their own
games.
You can download this testing
framework.  There is a link at
the end.
With it you can create tests
that add actions and assertions
that refer to game elements.
So let's see how that works.
So here's air test, and I'm just
going to select game elements
and add an action to touch a
game element.
I can wait for a game element to
exist, or I can assert that the
game element is visible.  It's
that simple.
Like demo loops, these tests can
be run locally.
They can also be run in Firebase
Test
Lab across a wide array of
devices.
Now, here's the goal creation
screen of fitness bud.
Now, my fitness goals are pretty
modest as you saw earlier.
It's a good day if I don't fall
off a treadmill.
With this screen users get to
create fitness goals and share
them with all of their fitness
buddies.
Now, obviously, fitness bud
wants to
create tests that cover this
part of the app as well.
Now, typically this involves
laboriously writing tests in one
of the
many testing frameworks, such as
expresso or UI automater, and
then
keeping the tests updated as the
UI evolves.
>> RICHARD GAYWOOD: Let me
quickly ask,
how many have had to rewrite
dozens or hundreds of tests
because you made a small change
in your app?  Right.
It's really painful, right?
This happens to me, too.  This
is a really painful situation.
>> JUSTIN BROUGHTON: This is
the exact
reason why we built Espresso
test recorder.
He is express Seo test recorder
is part of Android studio, and
with it you can quickly record
he is express Seo tests by
simply interacting with your
device running your app locally.
With it we create lots of tests
that
cover the non-OpenGL parts of
fitness bud.
You can create them in JV or (?
) But if your UI does change,
you can go in and re-record the
tests.  Let's see how this
works.
This is Android studio here.
I'm going to choose to record an
Espresso test.  I pick my local
pixel 2, which is running.
Then compiles and installs my
app and brings up this event
window.
At this point I get to enter my
name,
click on an avatar, and it
records the events all there in
that window.
Next, I want to add an
assertion.
So adding an assertion involves
pulling a screenshot from the
device so that I can select
elements in that screenshot on
which I want to assert.
I'll do that, click on an
element, and then I'm going to
click okay.
I get to choose JV  Java or
Kotlin.
I choose Kotlin and click okay,
and there's any Kotlin test
class.  It's that simple.
With Espresso test recorder, you
can modularize your testing.
You can create test snippets for
the commonly used functions in
all your
tests, such as logging in or
filling out a search form.
So with all that free time, all
those
excuses for not going to the gym
simply evaporate.
So now fitness bud has a battery
of
tests, and all they have to do
is add them to their continuous
integration system.
Now every time they make a
change they can be much more
confident -- this is the beauty
-- that it did not break the app
in some obscure way.
>> RICHARD GAYWOOD: Speaking as
a developer myself, peace of
mind like that is honestly
priceless.
>> JUSTIN BROUGHTON: But
fitness bud has to run on the
myriad of devices that people
drag to the gym.
How do they make sure that the
app runs well on all those
devices?
Well, they could buy a whole
bunch of devices, hook them up
to a workstation, and stick them
in a closet somewhere.
Fitness bud's closet is full of
gym
bags because they practice what
they preach.
Maintaining a device closet is a
really hard activity.  Trust me
on this.
Not only do you have to keep the
devices
online and updated, but you also
have to
procure new ones as the old ones
die or explode, and fresh ones
come out onto the market.
Fitness bud would much rather be
cussing
code or pumping iron, so what's
the alternative?
>> RICHARD GAYWOOD: Justin and
I described how pre-launch
report offers free crawler
testing on about ten
devices to every APK that
fitness bud uploads.  You can go
much further with the Firebase
Test Lab using a broad array of
devices covering screen sizes,
Android
API versions and different OEMs
and chip sets.
>> RICHARD GAYWOOD: To
illustrate this we recently
added prerelease P devices that
you can now all test on.  What
I'm most excited today to
announce -- wait for it -- is
our new support for iOS.
It was already up there.  You
already knew.
So you can sign up for a beta
through the Firebase console.
There's a link at the end.
Fightness bud is a global
application.
As such, it needs to be tested
on a
whole bunch of different
languages.
Both FirebaseFirebase Test Lab
and the play console allow you
to do just that
with Firebase Test Lab, you can
run your
tests on any locale you wish,
and pre-launch report recommends
the most
popular languages amongst your
users.
So now there should be no reason
for fitness bud to waste all
that time and
energy maintaining a device
closet which gives them even
more time to spend at the gym.
It's kind of a wonder they get
any coding done, actually.
HRZ like  Like in the pre-launch
report, Firebase Test Lab also
gives you comprehensive test
results like crashes and A and
Rs.
Video and screenshots, logs,
performance metrics, and a map
of the activities the crawler
found.
The video and screenshots are
especially
important to help fitness bud
verify
that their app looks good and
runs well
across all those screen sizes.
Fitness Bud verify that their
app looks good and runs well
across all those screen sizes.
Let's look at how easy it is to
quickly
run a test in the Firebase
console.
Firstly, I want to quickly point
on your iOS support, there it
is.  You can't dismiss that
coach mark, but it's there.
We're going to run a robotest.
Robotest is the simplest of
tests.  All it requires is that
you give us your app.  Now, I'm
going to quickly choose an app
at random from my hard disk
there and upload it.
While it's uploading, you'll
note we can also upload a
roboscript, which we won't do
here.  Now I choose any devices
from the many devices.  Some are
deprecated, which means they
exploded and we can no longer
procure them.
I'm going to go with the default
two devices, but I want to add
some locales.
I'm going to add Chinese.
I'm going to add Arabic when I
get there.
And then lastly I'm going to add
Spanish.
Then I'm going to fix the
locales because I really only
care about
portrait mode, and then fix the
locales, please.
There we go.  There we start a
test.
An eight test because it's two
devices against four locales.
In the background it willal  --
allocate eight devices and
figure those
devices setting the locale, the
orientation.
It will then install my app on
all
those devices, and then it will
run a five-minute robotest,
which will take five minutes.
So -- oh.  Thank God it's done.
All right.  There we go.  I'm
going to pick the first of
these.  You see we have logs.
We have screenshots.
We have an activity map, which
is a map of the activities we
visited.  You have performance
information,
which is tied to the video, so
you can see what's happening in
your app at the time of the CPU
spikes or the frames per second
drops.
You can find instructions on the
webs
and documentation site for how
to hook test lab up to many
common, continuous integration
systems like Jenkins or circle
CI or team city.
We have a number of customers
who are doing exactly this.
Testing their app multiple times
a day.
Test lab is helping them find
problems
way before they end up affecting
their users.
And best of all, you can get
started for free!  With our
spark billing tier.
So it's really that simple.
>> RICHARD GAYWOOD: Justin and
I hope our talk today gives you
renewed inspiration for your
testing strategy.  It doesn't
have to be difficult to test
comprehensively.
Let the pre-launch report and
the Google Play Console Google
Play Console
help you discover crashes,
performance issues, security
vulnerabilities and
soon accessibility warnings with
SFWLER configuration required
from you.
Publish an APD to the open and
closed
testing tracks, and the report
will be generated for you.  You
can go further to the auto
generated reports with custom
log in credentials, roboscripts,
deep linking
and demo loops to help us test
your app better.
>> JUSTIN BROUGHTON: If you
want to test maybe more often
and comprehensively, look at
Firebase Test Lab, which in
addition to the features
Richard just mentioned, also
allows you to create and run
your own tests.
So take a picture of this if you
wish.  You have a couple of
seconds to do that.
I think most people have already
done that.
>> RICHARD GAYWOOD: We'd really
love to hear more for you, so if
you have XHEPTs or suggests use
the link in the I/O app or come
and find us in person after the
talk.
( Applause )
>> JUSTIN BROUGHTON: Of course,
we really want to thank all of
you're users, both big and
small.
>> RICHARD GAYWOOD: And also to
all of
you, many thanks for joining us
at this punishing early hour.
We really understand, obviously,
that the big party was last
night.  We have a few minutes
left if anyone has questions or
we can take them privately as
well afterwards.   Okay.  Thank
you very much.
>> JUSTIN BROUGHTON: Thank you.
( Applause )
( Session concluded )
.  .  .
.
:
>> Thank you for joining this
session.
Grand Am bass DORs will assist
with directing you through the
designated exits.
We will make room for those that
registered for the next session.
If you registered for the next
session in this room, please
clear the room and return via
the registration line outside.
Thank you.
.
:
Build reactive mobile apps with
Flutter
>> FILIP HRACEK: Morning and
welcome to
the build react apps with
Flutter.
>> >> MATT SULLIVAN: Flutter
lets you build beautiful apps.
It gives you the ability to
create fluid and customized
sophisticated UIs.
There's a few examples to show
you the
different range and types of
apps to build with Flutter.
At the heart of Flutter's UI is
a powerful reactive model.  I'll
give you the 30-second summary
how it works and then we deep
dive into things.
In Flutter all UI components are
widget.
We have a widget that's a
button.
Secondly, you take these widgets
and
compose them together to create
complex UIs.
We refer to the
widgetary and they also rebuild
it when the state changes can it
relieves you of doing the task.
When we call set state on the
greeting
widget, it's going to
automatically redraw itself.
That's great and wonderful, but
building complex apps is never
easy.  Apps typically have
thousands of UI components, but
they have very
complicated and potentially
sophisticated state reacting
with UI
components at various different
times in the app.  The good news
that Flutter provides
all the tools necessary not only
to
build UI but handle complex
Dataflow and stay in your app
that fits in elegantly
well with Flutter's reactive
model for buildings UIs.
Flutter's UI patterns are
well-known and well documented,
but the reactive strategies to
handle state not so well-known.
So we're going to focus the talk
on how to do that.  We take you
on a journey.
We look at the foundations of
Flutter and State so show you
the basis of how it works.
We explore how State and the
weed jetary can be married
today.
How you can use Flutter streams
to elegantly manage State in
your app.
In each we do live coding and
clearly nothing is good or
wrong.  We do some live coding,
and these examples will be
relatively simple, but
we want you to keep in MIENDZ
how
they're scaled out to larger
apps and importantly the
examples here have been derived
from production apps built with
Flutter both by Google and by
other partparties.
So let's dive in and look at
managing State in the simply app
we can think is, which is the
incrementer app, which is what
you get out of the box when you
do Flutter create.  The reactive
model is straightforward for UI
and State, but it's a little
different to how things are
handled with Android and iOS.
We're going to dive in by
looking at
this app, and we look at a
common pitfall that typically
catches peel out when they
initially start to think about
reactive systems in general.
Filip.
>> FILIP HRACEK: This is an
exciting moment because I break
an app on stage at I/O.  That's
exactly the opposite of what you
normally want to do on stage.
This is in the name of learning
and science.  So it's okay.
So if you're not familiar with
this app, this app is very
exciting.
It shows you a number, and it
lets you increment that number.
The important parts are there's
the (?) And there's the built
method that creates the UI.
Here's the widget that shows
that number, number 4 right now,
and here's the floating action
bottom, which is this guy over
here, which lets you change that
variable.
Now, imagine that this was a
much bigger app, and we wanted
to put them all a little more
structured to it.
We would do that often by
extracting
parts of the built method into
its own widget, right?
So I'm going to do just that.
I'm going to take this out,
create a
new widget called incrementer,
and I'm just going to paste the
code over here, right?
So we're not done.  As you can
see, there's red, squiggly lines
over there, which means we have
a problem.
The problem is that we cannot
actually access the
countervariable from here,
because we're in this class
while the countervariable is in
this class.
All right?
There are many ways to solve
this problem, but I have
something very special in mind.
I'm just going to make the
variable global, because I can.
So there you have it, folks.
>> MATT SULLIVAN: To handle
State and Flutter, you make it
global, right?
>> FILIP HRACEK: No. We try to
make the point here and try and
break this app, so please don't
make your variables global.
We're going to fix this in two
minutes.  You know, stay with
us.
So we have -- we fix the
squiggly lines, so let's see if
this app actually works now.  It
doesn't.
Now, why is that?
We can add a thing here to see
if the countervariable has
actually changed, and we see
that it is.
It's now at 12.
The user doesn't see it.  Why is
that?
The reason is we call said state
in the wrong widget.
We break the contract of set
state, which is that you call
set state when you're changing
the state of the widget.  We're
want changing the state of the
floating action button here.
We're changing the state of the
widget above it, all right?
And that way Flutter doesn't
know -- Flutter tries to rebuild
that floating action button, but
that doesn't do anything with
our text over here, is I'm going
to fix it now.
>> MATT SULLIVAN: We need to
move set state in the
appropriate widget where we want
to show the change or the
mutation of the state.
So Filip will move it back into
the home page widget, and
thankfully we tonight have
global state any longer.
Wonderful.
So what we're going to do then
is what we need to do.  We need
to pass down a reference to
that function so it can be
called by the child widget.
We update the incrementer widget
and past through the function
through the constructor.
This gives us a classic
call-back method of being able
to call the function in the
parent widget, and that should
probably just work.
>> FILIP HRACEK: It works!
Awesome.  Back to the slides,
please.
So that was great and it was
pretty easy to fix, but you can
imagine that if you
have a much larger app with a
lot more widgets, this could be
a problem.
Let's imagine that you have --
you need state over here and you
have state
somewhere over here, and now
what you need to do if you
follow that pattern I just
showed you, you need to pass
down the State down the widget
tree.  That means that all the
widgets that are in the path
need to know about this state,
even though they don't really
care.
And that breaks re-use and
breaks separation of concerns,
and it also potentially makes
the app rebuild much
larger portions of this state or
of the UI that you would want.
You only want the leaf notes to
be rebuilt.
So I've hopefully highlighted
two
problems here or two challenges
here.  First, how do I access
state that doesn't necessarily
live in the widget where I need
it?
Second, how do I notify other
widgets that they should
rebuild?  I'm going to --
again, I'm going to score this
pattern that I just showed you
with a thumbs-down on both
accounts, because while it is
easy in a simple app, in a
big app it gets more
complicated.
I think we have a better option
here.
>> MATT SULLIVAN: Okay. So
let's look at how we can handle
state and the concept of passing
State up and down the widget
tree without having to expose it
to all the widgets in between
that don't need to use it.  So
Flutter has out of the box what
is
called an inherited widget, and
what an inherited widget does is
holds state and
it allows you to propagate that
state efficiently down the
widget tree.
It will rebuild that widget tree
when that state -- when that
state is mute at a timed or that
state changes.  That sounds
promising.
They might help to solve this.
What does this look like?  You
have an inherited widget.  We
put it in here.  As opposed to
having the passed down REFRNTSs
to, we can use the build
context in any of the build
methods to get an access to the
instance of ha state and use it
directly Warren Jeffs
the -- within the widgets
themselves.
Here I have my cleverly named my
inherited widgets which extends.
In here you see I have placed
some state.  Perfect.  How do I
access that?
Well, I can access it by firstly
placing my inherited widget into
my
tree, gives it some state, and
then building the widget tree
beneath that.
After that I access it by using
the build context to get a
reference to that widget and
access the state.  That sounds
promising.  That's good.  Sure
now I can access the state
anywhere in the tree and keep
the rest of the code dry.  My
tree rebuilds the state changes,
so that's okay.  As you notice,
my state was final.  That's not
very helpful if you actually
want to mutate your state.
Now, it's not hard to layer in
mutation with inherited widget.
It's a bit of boiler plate.
What we do is look at a library
called scope model, and it's an
external package built on top of
inherited widget and it gives us
access and more fine-grained way
of rebuilding parts of
our tree, and it allows us to
mutate state as well.
So lacking looking at code real
quick, scope model equates to
the inherited
widget and it has a descend DANT
that gives us access to the
state.
I want to show it in real code
to show it working, but I don't
want to show it
in the incrementer app, because
that's pretty simple.
Filip and I knocked up a
shopping cart example.  It has
three areas where you need to
handle your state.  We got a
cart page, which shows the list
of items.
We have a cart button, which
shows the number of items in the
cart and we have a grid of
products where each product is
tapable and should add something
to the cart.
So let's jump over to my laptop.
Let's take a look at this.
Perfect.  Okay.  Here we have
the app, which is already
running.  You can see I have a
grid of products, and at the
moment it's showing a snack bar
at the bottom.  We have my cart
button, which is hard-coated to
show zero, and we have a cart
page which currently is showing
empty.  There is no state
anywhere in here at the moment.
These are all stateless widgets
and just looks pretty if you
consider this to be pretty.
We're not designers, but there
you go.
What do we need to do?
First, we need to define our
model.  So I have created a cart
model.
It extepid the model and it has
a cart object holding our state.
We have three different ways to
interact with this.  We have a
getter to pull down the list of
cart items and we have item
count, which gives us the number
of items in the cart, and
strangely enough we have
an add method or function that
allows us to place a product in
the cart.
Notice here when I mutate or
change the state, I call
notified listeners.  The way
scope model works is when you
have a decent dent widget, they
observe your state and listen
for changes.  When it changes we
call notify listeners and all of
those widgets are notified that
stages change and they will
rebuild.  So the whole tree is
not being rebuilt, only those
widgets that are listening to it
and the things below them will
be rebuilt.  Perfect.
So let's see how I can use that
model to inject some state to my
app.  So what I'm going to do is
I'm simply going to place my
state at the top-most level of
app to begin with.  What I do is
I'm going to wrap this in
a new widget, and it is going to
be a scope model.
As we can see here, it takes a
model
and a child, so we can keep this
sub tree as a child, and I can
place a model.
I create a new instance of cat
-- no cart model.  Now I have
state existing at the top of the
tree.
I need to access that state.
How do I do it?
Look at the button.  You see at
the moment it's hard coded to
show zero.  What I do is I'm
going to follow the same type of
pattern and wrap this in a
new widget, and this time I'm
going to use a descendant
widget.  I type it so IT what
type of model to look for, and
this doesn't take a child.  It
takes a builder, which will
provide me with the model.  So
I'm going to change my child to
builder, and this is a function.
I need the build context because
that's
how inherited widget finds the
-- or gets a reference to it.
We have an optional child, which
I don't use, and we have a
model.  Great what can I do now?
I should be able to simply do
model.item count.  Perfect.  We
have to do one more thing to get
it to work.  We have to add
products.  I'm going to do it
super quick.  Here we have the
grid and individual products,
and again, I follow the same
pattern and wrap this in a
descendant widget.  I'm going to
type it.  I'm going to do that
properly.  Then, again, I'm
going to change this
to a builder, make this a
function, take
my context and my model.
So now what we can do in here is
we have all of this snack bar
code, which I can
get rid of, and I should be able
to do model.
add and we have a product.
Okay.  So this is all hot
reloaded.  I placed state in
there and don't have
to restart my app, and we'll see
if this works.  There we go.
So we went from stateless to
stateful.  I haven't changed the
structure of my app.
All I did is layered in a few
extra widgets, and with the way
that this half is built, this
has worked nicely.
>> FILIP HRACEK: This is nice,
Matt.  Didn't you say when you
modify the centers, you rebuild
the things below
the decent he notes that means
we're rebuilding the products
every time?
>> MATT SULLIVAN: As we pointed
out before, we're rebuilding
this button but also rebuilding
all of these products, which is
bad.  Not great.  Why don't we
fix that real quick, because
scope model descendant has a
rebuilt on changeded  flag, and
I can set that to false.  So you
shouldn't see any difference
here.
What's happening now is these
product squares are not being
rebuilt.
I already implemented descendant
for the cart page because you
don't need to see my type this a
third time, but it's exactly the
same model there.
Perfect.  So let's jump back to
the slides.  Thank you.
Great.  So what does that get
us?  Accessing state.
We can access state arbitrarily
down the tree without having to
mess with intermediate widgets.
Perfect.  We have a reasonably
elegant means to
notify the widgets by the
descendant observing for state
change and rebuilding when it
changes.
Minimal rebuild I give a
thumbs-down because I had to be
reminded by Filip
because I constantly forgot
every time we rehearsed to do
that we had to not rebuild at
that part.
There's a cognitive load at that
point for the developers.
Should is this rebuild or not
rebuild?  What will happen?
When you evolve the app, you
have an additional level of
needing to worry about this.  I
don't think this is great, and I
think we probably need a better
solution to that.
Funny enough, we look at Flutter
support for Streams.  How
Streams can be built to fit in
with the reactive model and how
they can solve this very
problem.
>> FILIP HRACEK: Thank you.
Let's talk about Streams.
If you're more FOM with the term
Observables, they are very
closely related, and for the
purposes of our talk, they are
basically interchangeable.
So if you think about
application development, Streams
are everywhere.
Every user input is a stream of
a synchronous event, and every
interaction with the underlying
system is a stream of a
synchronous event.  Every
interaction, obviously, with the
outside world through network is
a stream of synchronous events,
and crucially if you think about
it, all
your updates to the UI is a
stream of a synchronous event.
So people who are familiar with
reactive X and reactive
programming in general probably
know where I'm going with this,
but suffice it to say, it makes
sense to
think about UI programming as
managing stream of synchronous
events.
The good news is they have a
good for
streams and has had that for a
long time.  The streams have all
the usual bells
and whistles you expect like
stream
transforming, mapping, folding,
and so on.
Dart even has language level for
streams like asynchronous
generators, the yield keyword or
a wait for.
So we have this concept of
streams in Dart, and it is used
throughout the Dart eco-system.
Then we have this, you know,
concept of reactive extensions
and reactive programming.
On top of that, there's a
package
called Rx Start, which builds
the
reactive extensions on top of
the inherent streams in Dart.
So this is really great.  How
that fits into Flutter?
Well, Flutter has this widget
called stream builder, which is
a exactly what you would think
it is.
It is a widget that takes
it as an input and rebuilds
every time there's a value in
the stream.  Anytime you have a
stream when you
describe to a Firebase database,
you can
use stream builder to rebuild
your UI.  That's pretty cool.
Wouldn't it be more awesome to
have an architectural pattern to
build our apps?
Imagine that you have a big app,
and it has some widgets that
take user input.  Therefore,
they have streams of a
synchronous event coming from
the user, and then you have
other widgets that can be
anywhere else in the widget
stream
that try to update whenever
there's a state change.
Now, you cannot just simply, you
know, link those two together.
You need something in between.
We'll call that business logic
for now.
So you need to stream the events
from
the widgets that have buttons
and inputs to the business
logic.  Then magic happens, and
the business
logic publishes streams of data
changes
to widgets that are interested
in it, right?  These can then
rebuild.
Crucially, your publishing
separate streams, so the other
widget could be interested in a
completely different
aspect of data and it will just
subscribe to that stream.
So it won't rebuild anytime
there's any change to your
model.
It will only rebuild when
there's a change to that
specific aspect of the model.
So let's have a closer look.  We
have streams as inputs and
outputs.  How would that look
like in Dart?
We would have an object that has
syncs of events as inputs.
Syncs is the input of a stream.
You put things into it.  Then
you can listen to it on the
other end.
And then there's the stream of
data that's output, right?  So
pretty simple.
Now, in our example with a
shopping
app, the simplest possible cart
would be to have a sync of
product called addition to which
you would just shove your
products into.
And then it would have a stream
of enter  integers called item
count which would
update every time the item count
changes.  So internally at
Google we call these
business logic components, so
that is block for short.
Let's switch the computer and
implement it real quick.
This is my computer.  I have the
same app.  It doesn't change or
currently work,
and we need to implement this
pattern.
So I already have a cart
provider that
uses inherited widget, so that I
can access the cart --
this object from anywhere in my
tree.
And as you can see, I'm creating
this object here, and then I'm
accessing it
in different parts of my app but
not doing anything with it yet.
Also, if you look at the object
now or the component now, it is
pretty empty.
It only has the underlying
model.
So what I'm going to do is I'm
going to first implement the
sync of products, the input, the
streaming input, right?
I'm going to very quickly code
it up, and then I'm going to
tell you what it does.
So it's going to be a sync of
product called addition.
This is that input stream that
you can
access externally, and then this
is
backed by a stream controller
called
addition controller, which is a
stream controller is a basic
class in the
stream library in Dart, called a
library.  So that helps us, you
know, listen to the stream of
things that are coming from
outside.
Now, how would you use it in
your app?
You would just go to the product
squares and wherever you are
trying to, you know, add to the
streams of events,
it would just say, hard block,
the sync, and then we want to
add to the sync and in this case
we want to add to the products.
Right?
Coming back, we want to also
code the
output, which is a stream of
item count.  So again, let me
quickly do that.
Item count is a stream of  (?
) And it's backed by a behavior
subject.  Behavior subject is
coming from reactive X, and it
is a different kind of stream
controller that has memory of
its latest value.
So whenever you listen to it, it
will give you the lightest
value.  This is in contrast to
normal stream controllers or
Veeams where when you listen to
it, you have to wait until the
value changes.
That could be, you know,
sometime in the future.
In our case we want to have
always the latest value -- the
moment that we listen to a
stream.
Now, how would we use that?
Well, now we get to use the
stream
builder class, so we have the
cardboard on here.  We had it to
Lynn to changes to the
item count, so I'm going to wrap
it with a stream builder of
integers.
It will Lynn to the item count
stream.
And in here I access the
snapshot the
datasesdatases, which is the
latest item KOUN.  So we have
this.
Now all we need to do is merge
the streams together.  So that's
what I'm going to do just now.
So this is where Filip will make
the
>> MATT SULLIVAN: This is where
Filip will make the magic happen
behind the scenes.
We need to listen for changes on
that, because we're not
capturing it at the moment.
We need to add those products to
the cart itself.  What Filip is
doing now is getting access to
the stream and Lynning to it,
and then the product will be the
event coming in and all we need
to do at this point, then, is
add that product to the cart.
Great.
Now we have state managed.  We
need to make sure that item
count is always updated when
products are added, and we just
need to do what we
did in the opposite direction,
to add
the item count to the item count
stream and we're done?
>> FILIP HRACEK: We're done.
Back to the slides, please.
As you can see, we were able to
implement this business logic
component pretty quickly.  It's
a little more complicated, but
it
gives you a lot of cool stuff.
First of all it's just streams
in and streams out.
Whatever happens in the
component you don't care about.
As a Flutter UI.  Then we could
add more things to this block,
right?
We could add a stream of total
costs, so whenever the costs of
the cart changes, you probably
want to update
your user to give it that.  Then
you have a stream of lists of
cart items, which is the items
that you want to always update
whenever you add
something to the cart or remove
from it.
So that is, cool, and again
these are different aspects of
our model that we want to show.
Now, I have a problem with one
part of this, and that is this
part.
We're streaming the total cost
as integers.
That makes sense internally in
the
component, and it is a numerical
value after all.
What it leads to is code in your
views like this.
You have to somehow convert or
format the numerical value to
some kind of string, right?
Which is if you think about it,
this is business logic.  This
shouldn't be in views.  So you
can go back to your cart block
and just change this to a stream
of stream that is already
formatted.
Whenever you want to show your
total
cast, you just stream the
formatted one.
If you just re-use that same
business logic that's inside the
component now.  That gives you
another cool thing, and
that is that if you add a new
sync or new input to the model
-- sorry.
To the component, for example,
sync of locale, so users now can
change anywhere in your app they
can change from a U.S. shop to a
EU shop.
Now, you can pipe this change as
a
stream to the total costs, so
internally in the block you will
update the total cost stream.
Even though it was the numerical
value is still the same.  That
means that anywhere in the app
that user changes this, you
don't need to think about it as
a developer.  It will always
update anywhere else the total
costs.
This would be a real pain to
implement any other way.
We have this nice flow of data
and events.
We have widgets that only Lynn
to what we need to know, and
we're using good
old stream builders to make that
work.
>> MATT SULLIVAN: Look what we
have now.
Accessing state in Filip's
example was
solved by using the inherit the
widget pattern to pass access to
the block down the tree.
We now have very fine updating
on change, because we have
different aspect
'of our data represented by
different streams.  Those
widgets subscribing to those
streams only rebuild when those
aspects of data changes.
Finally, we now have the
converse.  We have mutating
state by pumping data
or requests to mutate state into
the business logic where we
observe for change and we can
update it now.
There's a nice pattern of
pushing data
in via streams and updating via
streams, which we think is very
elGAPT.  This is great, but you
all have options.
Set state works fine if you have
a
shallow tree and your app is
fairly simple.
Scope model is a fantastic way
for a model which is relatively
straightforward passed up and
down and change on a tree of
arbitrary depth.  For those that
like the Redux pattern,
there is an excellent Redux
package built for the community
for Dart and Flutter, which will
give you that pattern and you
can use that as well.  If
there's one thing that we'd like
you to take away from this, it's
that
Flutter's widgets in combination
with
Streams gives you a reactive way
to not only handle the UI but
the flow of data through your
app and handle the updating of
your UI when that data changes.
So we highly recommend you go
and
check out Dart Streams and the
RX Dart package as an option for
building state in your apps.
We'd love to hear from you.
Please go to the site and give
us some feedback.
All of the code you've seen
today is in Filip's GitHub
account.
I did some, and he didn't write
everything.  We showed you the
code we showed, but we have a
Redux implementation and a
couple others to check out.  A
shout-out to the cookbook that
us and the community have been
working on.  There's some
wonderful patterns in there from
everything from widget
creation to networking to JSON
and it's grate place to go.  Two
other talks happened prior to
this.
Fortunately, we have a time
machine
called YouTube so you can go
back in time.
If you want to learn about
building apps, check them out.
They're good talks.  I would
like to say thank you for your
time.
>> FILIP HRACEK: Thank you.
( Applause )
.
>> Thank you for joining this
session.
Grand Am bass DORs will assist
to get through the exits.  We
will make room for those that
registered for the next session.
If you registered for the next
session in this room, please
clear the room and return via
the registration line outside.
Thank you.
( Session ended )
.
Effective ProGuard
keep rules for smaller
applications
>> STEPHAN HERHUT: Hello. A
Stephan and I'm a staff engineer
at Google where we work on
compilers and
runtime systems and most
recently I'm working on R8 which
is the SNU shrinker.
If you attended yesterday's sec
on Android studio and you heard
about how to use it.  I don't
want to talk too much about it.
I want to focus more on key
rules.  So what are keep rules?
It's the language that ProGuard
uses to specify what you need to
keep in the application.  When
we built R8 we wanted to use the
same language because we want to
a
drop-in replacement for
ProGuard.  You can resues the
existing rules and try it
easily.  I mentioned building
something that is compatible to
that degree required us to quite
deeply understand what ProGuard
key rules actually mean.  Today
I want to use this opportunity
to share some of that knowledge
with you.  I also want to take
you on a journey to understand
what it takes to give an
application to come up with
effective rules to shrink it to
the minimum.  Before we go
there, let me ask you the
questions.  Who has used
ProGuard before in some way or
shape?  Wow, that's a lot of
people.
So who of you is using ProGuard
today
in the released production app
on the Play Store?  That's a
little less, but you're a great
crowd.  Thank you for doing
that.
Our estimates show that only
about a quarter of applications
on the Play
Store actually use the rules.
There's a big room for
improvement.  Why it actually
matters to shrink application
size.  Of course, for me it
matters because I
help to build the shrinker and
want somebody to use it.
There's a lot of talk about next
building users and Android
deviceses and how to make the
user experience better.
What makes an entry level user
Android device, so one thing is
it's really resource limited.
If you think of these devices,
they typically have 512
megabytes of ram and
only have four gigabytes of
storage and quite often people
that use the devices
on areas where they have very
limited connectivity.
So for these users, size
actually makes a daily
difference.  When they decide of
all the apps they actually want
to use, which ones they
can afford to install, there
might be a small subset, and
it's bad for them because it's a
bad user experience but it's bad
for you as application
developers because it might be
your app that doesn't make the
cut.  It might be your app that
they want to use but they can't
use because they don't have the
space.
Now, you might say, okay, that's
not really my audience.  Next
building users entry level is
not where I see my application.
Even if your target really
high-end devices, the
fundamental truth is that
smaller is always faster.
That's quite obvious, because,
A, they
crown download fast and install
faster because there's less code
to compile.  That takes the time
to install.
Lastly and what users see every
day, they also start up much
faster because there's less code
to load.
So whenever I talk to people
about this and say, okay, you
have to care and make
them smaller, an answer I get on
is, hardware will fix this.
Devices are faster and more
storage and connectivity is
better.
That might be true, but it's not
a solution.  I have GRAF for
you.
So this shows the average size
of
installed apps on people's
devices.
As you can see, this has been
growing steadily, so in the
early days of Android we started
at about a megabyte
per APK, and by now we're at 32
megabytes on average for
installed applications.  So
clearly, hardware is not going
to fix this.
We have to do something about
it.  We have to make apps
smaller.
So let's look at this.
Where does this growth come from
and why are apps so big?
To give you an idea, I gave an
example here.
I built this app I called simple
weather, and the stress is
really on simple.
All this app does is takes
predefined
weather data and RENDs it as a
dynamic graph.  If you churn the
app, it will render in a
different size or install on a
different device, it will adapt
to resolution.
So the graph is truly dynamic
and the data isn't.
This is a really, really simple
app.
There's two things I found
surprising.  It took me all but
30 minutes.
Went on the Internet and looked
or the graph library and typed
in hundreds of lines of code.
There it is, my simple, little
weather app.  There was also a
negative surprise, and that was
the size.  I thought I built
something simple and small
because it makes it small, but
that's not true.
This app was two megabytes of an
APK.  Two megabytes to render a
graph.
Even when I installed this, it
turns
into a 4 megabyte blob of code
uncompressed.
Again you might say 4 megabytes
is not much.  The device has
lots of space.
Let's put this in perspective.
In the '60s we flew to the moon
with 60K of code.
That's a 60th of the application
size I had for my simple weather
here.  No matter how you turn
this, it's more complicated to
fly to the moon than rendering a
graph.
So what has happened here?
Why did we go from 60K flying
from the moon to 4 megabytes
rendering GRAF?
I think the reason is that we
fundamentally changed how we do
software.
So back then when they did the
software
for apolo, it was a dedicated
team that wrote this code line
by line.  Everything was on
purpose and hand-crafted, so it
was meticulously
crafted to fit into the 60K and
do exactly one thing, fly to the
moon.  Fast forward to today, I
build my app with components.
I just went to the web and
downloaded components and
stitched it together.  I had my
app.  There's a great advantage
to this, right?  It took me 30
minutes.  It was really easy and
super
productive, but there's a big,
big DAU drawback.  My
application was really big.
Let's look in the details.
Which components did I actually
use?
I brought youmy file and this is
the
default file Android Studio will
KRET for you.
I highlighted the components to
so it's easier to see.
The first is GUAVAA, and they
had a lot of convenient classes.
I wanted a mutable collections,
because I thought my static
weather data
is static so it should be in a
mutable collection, right?  The
other thing I used is Android
plot.  That's just a library of
I found on the Internet.
There's probably lots more
plotting libraries but I spotted
this one first.
It's really great and has a lot
of support for bar graphs and
charts, but they needed a line
graph and that's all I cared
about.
So let's look at what this means
for size.  How did these
components impact the size of my
application?
To get an idea, I went to the
APK analyzer.  If you haven't
seen this tool before, it's
really great.  It's part of
Android Studio.  You will find
documentation on developers at
Android.com.
It gives you deep insight into
what contributes to the size of
the APK.  They can do resources
and all kinds of thing, but I'm
only interested in the actual
code.
I highlighted the bottom there
for you.
There's this Google package with
4.1 megabytes and that's GAUF
YA.
I pay 1.
4 megabytes for the example.
There's something nor realistic,
which is Android plot.  That's
the second thing you see, and
that's 180K.
My plotting library takes 180K
of APK size.  Now, there will be
something in there that I don't
need, because my actual
application that's the EU part
down there is only 35K.  That's
the code I wrote.  You might
think 35K for 100 lines of code
is a bit much.
It is, because there's the auto
generator code, most of which I
don't need.
So this brings us to the
question,
how did it get from this where
you can
clearly see that Guava and
Android plot take the size and
the application is really small
to something more tailored more
like the
thing that they did for Apollo.
We won't get to something as
crafted
as that without dog  doing all
the investment, but there must
be a middle ground.
That really is where a tool like
ProGuard NRA comes in.
It takes the application and
removes
all the unused DMOENTs, so the
goal is to take a
componentialized build you make
to something as tailored as
possible and remove all dead
code.
Now, when I asked you all said
you used this, so you know it's
easy to enable because all you
have to do is you
have to head back to your build
file and flip this one flag.
If Android Studio generated this
for you, it will say enabled
false, you just flip that to
true, and tah-dah, you have a
small app.
I see some people shaking their
heads already here because
that's not really the truth.  So
I did this for my application.
I flipped the flag, and there it
was.
More than 200 build time errors.
Hooray.
So I looked at these errors and
thought, what are they trying to
tell me?  There's classes
missing and classes I haven't
even heard of.  What do I do?
How do I fix this?  Well, the
first solution, you search on
the Internet.
So I did.
I found this great piece of
advice,
which says, just put don'twarn
star into the ProGuard
configuration, and everything
will be fine.
Now, technically this is
correct, you put this in there,
and it will compile.  There's a
problem.
What this tells it, no matter
what happens, don't tell me
about it.
That means it will mask these
benign errors and really mask
all the errors you really care
about where something went
wrong.  So how can we improve on
this?
To do that, we have to actually
deep dive a bit into how R8
works.  Now, I will talk about
R8 here, because that's the tool
I helped build, but most of this
applies to ProGuard because it
solving the same problem.
What does R8 do?  It does two
things.  It does magnification.
Magnification is the process
where you
take very long class names and
replace them with short names
instead.
Some call this object fuss
indication, but it doesn't
obfuscate your code.
It makes it a little less hard
to read, but it's nowhere safe
for U.S. engineering.
Let's call it that.
The other thing it does is
shrinking.  Its a great name
from a developer's perspective
because it takes your app SP
shrinks it into a smaller app.
If you want to understand what
happens under the hood, it works
the other way around.  What
we're doing is doing tree
growing, which takes the entry
point of the application and
grows that until
we've seen everything that will
be executed at runtime.
Let's look at the example here.
So I found these graphics and a
box is a class that is all you
have to care about for now.
There's code in the boxes, but
don't read it just yet.  Another
thing on these graphs is that
everything on your right is
library classes.  That's part of
the Android system.
Everything on the left is your
application code.  The first
thing to realize here is
that library classes are always
live.
There's a very practical reason
for this.
It's because we can't shrink
them away anyway.
They're on the phone and part of
the system.  There's a technical
reason also.  For a static
analysis tool, we don't know
what this library class actually
does.  That is because the
runtime might call
to them at any point, and
there's very many different
libraries like different Android
versions and they might change
in the future.
From an analysis standpoint, we
have to assume that the library
classes are always live.
So let's assume we start our app
by calling the run method in the
app class.  So the first thing
we will have to do
to actually do this is we have
to extent wait this app class,
which means we create an
instance of the class app and
we also call the constructor.
That leads to both of them being
live.
That means we cannot strip away
the class and constructor.  So
far so good.  Next we have to
actually look at the code of the
KRUKTor to see what it will do
at runtime, and if you look at
the code, you will see it
you'lly creates a new instance
of class A.
Again, this makes class A become
alive.  We can no longer remove
it.
Note that class A doesn't
actually have
a constructor, so there's no
code to look it.
It only has a default that does
nothing interesting here.  It
writes the created instance to
this field and other field.
It's interesting to note here
that it
doesn't actually make other
fields live, because writing to
a field isn't observable.  You
have to read the field to know
that the field exists.
So now we have created the
instance of this class and
executed a constructor we want
to call the run method.
Again calling this run method
calls it live.
With every other live method we
have to look at it and see what
it does.  If you look at run it
first reading the other fields
to retrieve the instance, and
this is the moment where this
field becomes live.
Next we call A method on the
retrieved instance and that's
where A method and class A
becomes live.  Now we would like
at the code of A med and see
what that does and mark all
those effects.
So this is how the basic
analysis flow works.
Whenever you think about keep
rules,  you have to keep in mind
that's what it does.  How does
this relate to Android?  How do
we actually know the entry point
of an Android application?
Well, that comes from your
manifest file.  So this is a
very simplified manifest file.
One thing it does, it tells you
that the
activity has the class and the
graph as its implementation.
Now, neither R8 nor ProGuard do
understand manifest files, and
they shouldn't.  There's a
little tool that helps us to
understand them, and that's
called APT.
APT during a build will
preprocess all your resources,
and it creates corresponding key
rules for you.  Let's look at
this keep rule, and this is the
first keep rule so we'll talk
about it in detail.
So what it basically does is
says keep.  That's the simplest
form.  Everything I mentioned
now you have to keep.
Don't touch it or shrink it or
rename it.  We want to keep a
class, and then we have a fully
qualified class name, which
is my main class that came from
this manifest.  There's
something more here.  Just the
class name would only keep the
class.  It wouldn't actually
tell the system
that this class is also
substantiated, which is a big
difference.
To tell it about that, we have
to keep the constructors, and
that's what this in it line
does.
So this tells R8, we also need
the constructors and we will
extent YAT this at runtime.
Now R8 knows this is live and it
will look at the code.  Let's go
there.
This is the graph class and if
I've removed all the function
bodies and everything that's not
important.
What you will see here is it
actually doesn't have a
constructor.
So that means our analysis ends
right here.  We've seen the
class.
There's no constructor, nothing
to do.
Everyone one of that wrote an
Android
app knows it happens in the on
create method.  That's where the
actual configuration happens.
How does R8 know?  The keep rule
never tooled it to look at
uncreate.
Well, the trick here is that the
graph
extends this (?) Class, and if
you follow this you will see
that eventually that extends
activity.
Now, activity is a library
class, and as I said before, all
library classes are always live.
Hence, this on create method is
also live.  As this uncreate in
the library
classes is live, all this
overrides in
life subclasses look live.  You
have to keep that alive to
understand how it actually
works.  This is what marks on
create live.
Let's take a look.
This is my on create method, and
it looks like a standard on
create method.  It first does a
setup and delegates to the
superclass.
I want to highlight two things
here.  The first is this find
view by I.D.  This calls the
library method, and
what it does, at run dime it
dynamically returns an object
somewhere from your view based
on YUR layout.
Again, R8 cannot really
understand this.
Because this I.D.
is, again, defined in an XML
file somewhere.  This is my
layout.
You can see it says this XY
class is in my constraint layout
and has this ID plot.  How do
with figure this out in R8?
Again, APT comes to the rescue.
This might look similar, but it
tells R8
that your lay outuses this XY
class, and it will extent YAT it
at runtime.  It's always the
same principle.
Another thing I want to
highlight here
is that during this at plot
series where
you set up the plots, you use
another R
identifier, which is are this
R.XML.  They're different.  You
put them in your XML directory
in your resources.
There's no requirements so APT
can't actually understand them.
When you use this somewhere, you
are responsible for all the keep
rules that it may require.  Just
keep this in mind.  We'll come
back to that later.  So this is
the basic analysis flow.  This
is how this basically works.
Now you might ask, okay, 200
error messages, how does that
relate?  What went wrong there?
This analysis looks reasonable.
Why does it fail?
The reason is that the NALZ
analysis that we do is different
from what the VM does, and one
different in annotations.  The
Android VM doesn't really care
about annotations at all.  They
have no meaning at runtime,
unless you use protection.
So if an annotation class is
missing, the Android VM executes
the code because it doesn't even
look at them.  In comparison R8
has to understand annotation
classes because they might be
part of a keep rule, so R8 has
to find
these classes and understand the
hierarchy.
If R8 can't, it will warn you
about it.  That's a very common
source about these warnings, is
missing annotation classes.
The other thing is code R8 just
can't understand.  Here's an
example, which is class value.
So class value is a concept from
Java 7, but it's not available
on the Android platform.  So
this code will actually fail at
runtime.
When the VM tries to execute it,
it will tell you this class is
missing.  Why does this still
work?
Because the creators of guava
used this nifty trick to hide
the missing class.
They load the class via
reflection, and if that fails
they fall back to an alternative
implementation.
Now, want Android VM will
understand this at runtime.  It
will throw in an exception and
it gets caught and the
alternative is executed.  R8
cannot understand this code.
It's just too complicated to it
statically.  To if I can these
errors, you really have to look
at all the examples and find
where they came from.
Ultimately, that goes to these
five warning rules that you have
to add.
Now, the first three, they just
disable warnings about certain
annotations from
the checker framework and those
are
static NAMSZ frames not used at
runtime at all.  The bottom two
are two classes not readily
available on the Internet
platform, and they are typically
used by reflective records to
make it work at runtime.  Adding
these five rules, we get our
application to compile.
That wasn't bad, right?  So we
looked at it and added five
rules and tah-dah, we have a
small application.
Unfortunately, the runtime
behavior of
my application has changed just
ever so slightly because now it
crashes.
That's the other problem you
typically see.
Again, what happened here,
right?  I explained to you how
the analysis works.  That looked
all fine and reasonable.
The typical problem is
reflection.
Because by its mere nature,
reflection is about using a
dynamic runtime value to load a
method or a class.  In static
analysis, they can't understand
this.
Dynamic values are the enemy of
static analysis.
So how do we fix this?
Well, we have to somehow figure
out
how to tell R8 about these cases
of reflection and make R8
understand them.  That's really
what key rules do.  What did I
do?  I we want to the Internet.
Unfortunately, the developers of
Android
plot put up this rule that says
keep classes.
Keep some classes and star,
star.
What that means is it turns R8
to tell it not to touch Android
plot at all.  It will fix the
problem and run again, but it
will no longer shrink.
So this cannot be the point in
using R8.
How can we improve on this?
We can't unless we go on a
forensic investigation.  Where
is all this reflection happening
and what we have to add towards
the configuration to make R8
understand it?
Where do you find evidence?
The first place to look is the
the ADB log.  So I've
preprocessed this a bit here
so it's easier to read, but if
go in Android Studio, you can
filter by
process ID, and this is what you
will see.
So there is this lock statement
saying that file definition not
found for A.  As such, this is
not really helpful because I
don't understand what this is
trying to tell me, but it's
really great because it gives me
a place to look and the source
code.
So this is a big piece of
advice.  If you write these kind
of libraries and do a
reflection, put in log in
statements.  It's not so
important people understand the
message.  It's much more
important people will find where
the statement was generated.
Because I have this log in
statement here, I can look at
the code and see what it's
doing.
Here's plot Java, and you can
see down there it says (?) Not
found.  So what is going wrong
here?
As you can see, this does
reflection.  There's this class
and get field and
styleable class is a class
object.  Get field will get a
field from that class given the
name.
So this is an example of
reflection on a class.
How is styleable name defined?
That's where it went wrong.
It's tried to find a field code
A that seems a strange field
name.  This is how it's defined.
It's defined by means of get
class and get name.  We have to
understand what this does.  La
does get class do?  It's a
reflective invocation.  It will
return in the current class.  If
you're in this plot file and in
the plot class, the current
class is the plot class itself
but it can also be any of its
subclasses because at runtime
this method might run a
different
context depending on how the
virtual work.
Now let me get the name of this
class,
and this seems to return A.
Why did they name the class A?
They didn't.  The problem is mag
Knicks.
R8 went ahead and say the class
thought plot is a long name and
call it A.  We have to prevent
R8 from naming this
class or any of its sub
classes.
This is the corresponding keep
rule.  It says keep Android
plot.plot and that means R8
should keep the
class, not rename it, not
optimize it.  We also have to
keep all the sub classes, so we
have to say keep class
star extends come Android
plot.plot.
This will keep all subclasses of
plots and the plot class itself,
but is this actually what we
want?
If you think again about what
get class
does, it at runtime returns the
class of the current object.
Now, you can't only be the
current class if you have been
extent YATed.
If a class is never created,
there's no way to get it via get
class.  So our keep rules don't
have to keep extra classes.  All
we want is we want to prevent
them
from being renamed, and that's
where modifyrs come in.  This is
a modifier for you.  This still
says keep, but it says allow
shrinking.
So it tells R8, if you see this
plot
class, you're allowed to remove
it if nobody uses it.  If you
keep it, don't rename it or
optimize it.  This will fix the
problem, because now the plot
class at runtime is called
plot, as will be all the
subclasses.
So that was not too bad, right?
You look at the code and come up
with two key rules and the
application will run or not.
So it's still not working.  We
have to do more forensics work.
What do we do?
Go back to the ABD log, and the
message has changed.  We see a
different exception.  Again,
it's not really clear what this
is trying to tell me, but I have
an exception to look for.
This says error while parsing
key line paint that it's broke
with.
Why does this happen?  How do we
find out?  We look at the code.
Here's the corresponding method.
We take a class and get all the
methods,
and next we compare the name of
this method against some given
name we're
looking for two things can go
wrong here.  We get a set of old
methods so we might have removed
too many methods.  We get the
name of the methods so we might
have renamed them.  These are
the two errors conditions to
check, what you remove and
rename that you shouldn't?  I
have to admit it's hard to
figure out what this code really
does unless you're the library
developer.  So the person who
wrote this code initially knows
perfectly clearly ha this is
doing, and at that point it
would have been really easy to
write these keep rules.  So what
does this do?
Do you remember these?  We
configure what there's supposed
to look like.
Android plot can configure the
graph based on some XML file,
and this is what the file looks
like.  As you can see in there,
you will finds this line paint
that's broke with.  What this
library will do, it will
take this XML file and it goes
through
all the attributes in that and
it will
call corresponding setters and
getters on what it trying to
configure.  You call it the get
line paint getter and set the
stroke with property.  This is a
very standard pattern of
configuring something at runtime
and it's a really great feature.
If R8 sees this, it cannot
understand this.  They cannot
make the connection between the
XML file and actual classes.
Also, this is free form XML, we
don't have APT to help us.
Instead, we have to do this
ourselves.  This is the
corresponding keep rule.  What
do we need to do?
We don't want to keep any extra
classes because what we try to
do here is take an object at
runtime that already exists and
then we try to configure it by
calling getters and setters.
So that's why we use keep class
members.  That doesn't keep any
extra classes,
but it tells R8 if you keep a
class in the Android plot
classes, keep these members and
don't rename them.
What members do we want to keep?
We keep getters, and what do
they look like?  They return
some result, the three stars and
they start with get and
typically have no arguments.  So
that first line in there will
keep your getters.  Similarly,
we can keep setters.  They don't
return anything, but they start
with set and they take a single
argument of some time.
This rule will keep getters and
setters so at runtime it just
happens.
So one more keep rule.  Do you
think it will work now?  Let's
take a look.  And yes, we made
it.
So we edit a keep of keep rules
and our application is Rupping
again.  Was it worth it?
This was a bit of an investment,
right?  We had to look at the
code and figure out what it
does.  Was this SKRUR knee
worthwhile?
Let's go back to the APK
analyzer.
Here you see the results.
If you look at guava, that went
from 1.3 megabytes to just 8K.
I know that's very TREEJSly
because I
use a couple of couple few
classes in
this huge collection, but for
Android
plot it went from 180K to 100K.
If you look at the app, it went
from 35K to 2K.
2K is a lot closer to the 100
lines of code I actually wrote
pause we removed all the
unneeded parts that the build
system has created for us.
>> Again, I've created this
graphic for you to make this a
bit more visual.
As you can see guava nearly
disappeared.
Android plot halved and me app
turned into this little SLIFer
there.  So it was a bit of a
journey, but it really, really
paid off.  What's the take-away
lessons here?  I hope I was able
to convince you it actually
makes sense to look into size.
If you build an app, no matter
what your
target audience is, please
invest into size and keep rules
and use ProGuard or R8 to shrink
your app.  But also, I hope I've
shown you some ideas of how to
make this easier.  And the first
thing to really take
away here is you should consider
size
early on, because while you're
writing your code, it's really,
really easy to also write your
keep rules because you still
understand what that code is
actually doing.
All the code examples we looked
at, if you had just written
them, it would be easy to
understand why this goes wrong.
Also, you should add structure
to your code to ease describing
reflective use.  You remember
this getters and setters example
I had where I said, okay, all
classes in Android plot keep the
getters and setters?  These are
simpler with interface that
allows to tighten these up.
If you had an interface, say,
runtime configure object, you
could say in the keep rule every
object that extends runtime
configured, keep these getters
and SERTZ.   Setters.
It's independent of the actual
application to be part of the
library.
Lastly this sounds obvious but
it's important.
You should test the optimize
build.  The earlier you find
regressions, the easier to fix
them.  You will still remember
what they changed and it will
make it easy to come up with
keep rules.
If you are a library developer,
you
should really, really carefully
provide keep rules because
there's this multiplymultiplier.
If you make precise keep rules,
all the users of your library
benefit from it, and a lot of
apps will become smaller.
Don't make this an afterthought.
Invest into keep rules while you
build the library, while you
design the library.  Publish
them where where people can find
them, bought that's what we all
do.
We will search the Internet for
rules to use.  So put them on
your home page, put them in the
read me file, make it visible.
Lastly, consider using consumer
ProGuard
files when you're shipping via
the IAR system, because it makes
it completely transparent to
library users.
When they enable ProGuard, they
will automatically get your keep
rules.
Lastly, please give us feedback.
So we've built R8, and we've
tested it, and we believe it's a
drop-in replacement, but only
you can find that out.
If you use ProGuard today, give
R8 a try and tell us how it
worked for you.
If you're not yet using ProGuard
try
out R8 and see how got the
diagnostics this.  We have a
really responsive team and care
about your feedback.
Lastly, after this talk, you can
also see me at the sandbox or
find me outside if you want to
have a chat.
More immediately, you can also
find
feedback about this session
going to Google.
com
IO/schedule.
Thank you very much for your
attention.
( Applause )
>> Thank you for joining this
satisfaction.
Grand ambassadors will assist
with going to the designated
exits.
( Session ended )
Test
Everyone.
provisioning and authentication
with drinkings.I work on
security for Android Things.
>> WAYNE PIEKARSKI: I'm a
Things in IoT.  Thanks for
coming to our talk.going to talk
to you about the
devices connected to the internt
and to else.  We'll go through
the whole process end
talk about how Google software
platforms
IoT core help this make it
easier to do.
and you're here today is that
IoT is anything we've seen
before.
order in magnitude are larger
than PCs IoT larger than them.
devices on a daid basis.
tens of hundreds of them doing
interesting things.
give you some hints on how to
best build
how to connect them, secure
them, and so forth.
So firstly, let's discuss the
basics of Android Things.
Hopefully you've seen the intro
talk.that cover what Android
Things is.
Things is that it's based on a
system on little small board.
So the SOM contains the CPU, the
memory and supported by what we
call a board support package.
And this provides the drivers,
the
and everythings and updates and
security from Google.
it easier for developers to
build IoT
that they're secure and kept up
to date
kind of things that consumers
need now with their devices.
One other thing that makes
Android
supports really powerful types
of professing on device.don't
have to do things in the Cloud
but
processing and Machine Learning.
device because we have phone
level on the SOMs.
Android so you can use the
familiar
Android Studio and the existing
code you
developer.  If you're using
Android Things if Android
development before.
can learn more about that.
What we're going to focus on
today advantage of all these
things that come make your IoT
devices easier and better for
you.     So with that in mind,
let's get going to use
throughout this talk to about.
We're going to build and IoT
washing not?  Everyone's excited
about using Machine
therefore we should be using a
washing
that looks at your launder and
it
allow you to see how your
laundry's watt work.
We could could call our new
product TensorWash.
When we built this TensorWash
washing
a control panel on the front
because you it manually.
Because Android Things supports
you could have a screen on the
front,
audio playing.  That's one
option that you could build the
deluxe model of the machine.
However, if you want to make a
then you probably want to get
rid of the display.going to
leave that out for this example.
enabled and a few buttons on the
front everything is going to be
controlled by about in a bit.
The real magic of a machine like
connected to the Internet.
remotely, view what the camera
sees, you
cycle when you're at work or
driving home, whatever.user is
not in the house and potentially
anywhere in the world.
We don't want to restrict it
from being close by in the
house.
connection with a Cloud solution
behind that.
features so it can have points
for not wasting water too much.
It could report faults to a
service department.
support all this, the machine
needs Wi-Fi.
cheat by plugging an Ethernet
cable into it.     We have this
washing machine.Cloud.  We need
to share state with the Cloud
can control the device.  There
are many possible Cloud
services.We'll talk about a few
today.
kind of thing work, we need to
firstly network.
Many devices these days are
Wi-Fi-based.
requires an SSID and a
passphrase to join the network.
devices don't have a keyboard or
display be handled by the phone.
needs to spin up a Wi-Fi access
point of its own.
connects to it and sends the
log-in details over.
reconnects to the network and
uses that information.anything
goes wrong for any reason, the
knowing what happened.  It can
be problematic for some phones
Wi-Fi networks.  Many developers
find this challenging this
right.  We'll go through some
hints on how to better.
And next, the device needs to
know device are.  So you want to
make sure that the
and controlled only by the owner
of the that they trust.  So we
need some kind of authentication
that needs to be issued by a
server that control this token.
We put it on the device and then
what the device uses to contact
the
If the user factory resets the
forget this token and everything
else.
should reset itself so that a
different machine and none of
the previous history is
preserved.
So now, our TensorWash is all
connected and ready to go.So
when the phone device and Cloud
all
over a TLS connection such as
HGDPS so secure in that way.
We don't want to -- Google
services HTTPS.  We're starting
to enforce this by default.
it hard now for you to use
unencrypted the security
implications.
devices like this that everybody
does security properly.
tiny IoT companies making simple
toys
their device won't be the
problem and
unexpected impacts in ways you
didn't your device is out in the
world.     That's it.  That's
the key concepts of what you a
washing machine that we're
building to the Cloud.  So we
need to set up Wi-Fi.the
credentials.  We need to connect
with encryption.lot more to it.
I'm going to let Darren do a
deep dive
of the key concepts here and a
bit more what's going on. >>
DARREN KRAHN:  Cool.
talk about a few of these key
concepts relationships between
devices which is doing when we
provision devices.
These concepts are distinct but
intertwined.
talk about authentication,
authorization and attestation.
auction, to aukt something is to
prove
that it's authentic.
We aukt official documents and
signatures.
We aukt each others by face
recognition.  It's intuitive.
Computers aukt us by using
passwords.
time in our daily lives without
even thinking about it.
What about when one computing
another computing device?  This
is less intuitive.involves
secret data.
secret data and all other
computers don't.
that I the want talk to about.
bearer tokens.  These are very
common and will relate
TensorWash example.
So cryptographic keys and
.  This is how your computer
uses hchts server.
It verifies verifying
certificate and
you already test or that you
expect.
authored that authenticated is
something you trust.
needproof of a key.  It's not
transferred over the network the
private part of the key.
computer has possession of it
and it gives us proof of that.
So doing this right in practice
can
building these protocols can be
really hard.recommend you don't
build this yourself.that does
it.  If you use Android Things,
we have
HTTPS and TLS built in so you
deposit have to implement this.
I like to compare this to an
airport passport check.take your
passport and you come up to the
check.
there is going to validate
specific information on the
passport.They're going to verify
that it's from trust.  And then
they're going to do a proof
which in the case of the
passport is a the face of the
person standing in front of
them.
I also want to talk about bearer
tokens.little bit differently.
another in order to verify them.
computer that sends it but
meaningful to verifies it.
The token is implied by the
token and
decision as to whether it's an
authentic token or not.like to
compare this to the example of a
movie ticket.
to the ticket stand and buy a
movie your bearer token.
You present that token and it
you're in.  You pass it to your
friend and now that token and
they can get into the movie.
used to auction than in the
past.
with the user name and password.
your password on every page on
that site.
issue your browser a bearer
token and it
amount of time and have access
to your means on that website.
So you don't have to keep
entering time.
You can authenticate it once and
you
authentication mechanism from
that point forward.
So let's think about
authentication in the context of
IoT.There's a few aspects that
are worth calling out.
the authentication needs to go
both ways.
services and other guyses around
the
that device and that device
needs to
services and other devices
around it.
would authenticate a web service
the
such as HTTPS or TLS.
Authentication does not
necessarily identity.
Often we think of it that way,
but it necessarily have to be
that way.
restricted web service.
connect to that web service.
clients are actually instances
of that web service.authenticate
that it's one of your which one.
You can actually do anthat case.
We need to bind it to meaningful
expectations.can make sure we're
authenticating, what
authenticate.     Let me give
you a couple examples.
front of you and you want to
something physical on the
device.
display a code both on your
phone and that's a physical
binding of that authentication.
common experience when you do a
like that.     But you can also
use a sticker on the device or a
bar code.We'll talk about that a
little bit more.
an encrypted channel in order to
your authentication to that
channel.
standard protocol like TLS or
HTTPS, you.  You don't have to
worry about it.
something between two devices,
for
support that kind of protocol,
you need to think about this.
So let's go back to our
TensorWash at the authentication
that needs to happen.completely
unprovisioned state.
machine out of the box.
Let's assume our smart phones
are set up.
authenticate web service
services using
case we have a Google account
we've
those web services are able to
authenticate the phone.a two-way
authenticated relationship
there.     The first thing we
need to do is we this new
device.
We want to send it credentials
which valuable.  Wi-Fi
passwords, access to Cloud
services.
to make sure we're sending it to
the it over.
Once we've provisioned that, we
where we have two-way
authenticated TensorWash machine
and Cloud services.
here, Firebase and Cloud IoT
Core that
For both of these we want a
two-way Again, authenticating
web services.
HTTPS and we'll use different
forms
more later to authenticate the
device be provisioned during
this process from the phone.
So you may have noticed that
that didn't go both ways.  What
about this one in yellow.it okay
for the TensorWash to come out
authenticate the phone that's
going to set it up?
this way because this is really
common with consumer devices.
When they come out of the box,
there's a clear state.don't have
any notion of who their owner is
or who they trust.They're just
available to be set up.
this case.  Mostly that's okay.
with credentials it's going to
give out.
credentials so it's less
important.
that needs to authenticate the
TensorWash device.     But there
are cases, for example,
mass rollout scenarios where you
want set up.
It comes out of the box with a
notion
This can be as simple as taking
the
on the device so when it wakes
up and
server that fill it in with the
rest of information that it
needs to get configured.
bit out for our talk.
in a clear state.     So we've
talked about
whether something is authentic.
authorization which is checking
if
what it's trying to do.check.
You arrive at the airport with a
valid doesn't mean you're going
to pass the check.they're going
to see if you're scheduled for a
flight that day.
Just because your passport is an
you can pass.  Similarly with a
movie ticket head to the theater
with a movie ticket not get into
your movie.
different showing.  And there's
an authorization that
even though your movie ticket is
perfectly authentic.
So I want to use the example of
OAuth 2.0 for the web.
may or may not work for a given
IoT use case.
example and I want to pull in a
few concepts that are important.
Even if you don't use it, you
need to concepts.
The biggest is token scope and
token lifetime.can the bearer of
this token get access to?
describes when the token
expires.
There's this notion of refresh
ngsorness which accesses the
resource you're trying to get
to.
These tokens are short lived
narrowly scoped and
self-contained.
The resource server can be
optimized.back end lookup.  It
looks at the token it received
and decision with the
information there.     Refresh
tokens, on the other hand,
access tokens when the old
access token expires.lived and
more widely scoped.
for a variety of different
scopes.specifically.
What this enables, this enables
the
that's making the decision on
whether it
refresh token, it can decide if
there's authorization.  That's
what you want to have with IoT
as well.
You want to have that passive
sxrartion.  Soexpiration.  So if
it's revoked.
Once the access tokens expire,
there's access oh token.  You
don't want to be in a situation
have to pull an unused IoT
device out of
does a factory reset to
deauthorize it.passively.
This is a snippet from the spec
flow.  You can see in the middle
the access
access a protected resource
server in
the access tokens expire and an
error back.
refresh token get another access
token.you visual identities that
a little bit better.     Let's
think about authorization in an
IoT device.  We talked about
authentication needs
ways, authorization needs to go
both
think about it in both
directions.
access to the device, who can
send so forth.  What does the
device have access to?
does it have when it connects to
a web service, for example?
We want to use the principle of
least privilege.want to give
more privilege than necessary.
common problem with IoT.
just give the device total
authorization
connecting to because you won't
have any and everything will
just work.
only using 10% of that
authorization, if
hacked, now the attacker has
access to weren't using it.
You also want the expire -- I
ex-operation.  You want to be
careful when passing your
tokens.Tokens are made to be
passed for verification, for
example.
authenticated the recipient
before you send your token.
you're sending it to a web
service for it's over HTTPS.
provisioning a new device like
our
it before you send over the new
token.
As you'll see in a
manage tokens for you don't have
to management, which is great.
Let's go back and look at
scenario specifically.
We started on this state where
we the phone is authorized to
set up devices with Cloud
services.
The phone is authorized to set
it up policies about that.
Where we want to be after we
two-way authorization with
Firebase.
Firebase realtime database.
sync data up to the Cloud.the
device.  There's an
authorization where authorized
to give commands to the
authorized to push data back
into Firebase.
With Cloud IoT Core, we put the
because we're going to use it
for metrics.
out into the Cloud IoT Core
project.
push into that project.
We'll show you the details how
you set this up.
talk about one more key concept
and that is attestation.
Attestation is really proving
the
device with state, including the
current device.  It's a special
kind of authentication.
this to be possible, the device
needs to
of credential that can use to
prove itself.
the factory so when it comes out
of the
genuine instance of that
particular product.     It's
worth mentioning that
cryptographic key.  Instead of
the attestation assertion
the device saying I'm a genuine
device
it's a bit more like, this
particular
secure lil held by a device
running in a secure mode.
useful because it allows us to
bind the
else that uses the key, some
other kind instance.
Le' see in the example later we
use
connect to Cloud IoT Core.
So in Android Things
specifically
you can attestproperties.
twice device.  You can verify
device state like I was about.
The important one and the ones
we pull
verified boot state where this
device is
approved software for that
device.attributes of the
cryptographic key.today.
So this is what a certificate
chain looks like.levels deep.
At the top we have the Android
Things managed by Google.
Things attestation certificates.
the product specific CA.
context of the Android Things
developer with.  Every time you
create a product on
will be an intermediate CA
assigned to
So the next level we have the
device specific CA.to each
device in the factory.  This is
unique per device.
contains an ID for that device.
that box, this is the one that
it has.
application key and
certificates.
application and the certificate
is
device specifics A which is by
the on that device.
So back in our TensorWash
example,
with the TensorWash device up to
the phone.
verification, remember the phone
is authenticate the device.
That's where we're using
attestation.     So quick
review.  We talked about
authentication, that something
is genuine or valid.
that it is allowed it's doing
what it's
attestation that it's using a
computing device specifically.
Wane will show us how to do
these things with Android
Things. >> WAYNE PIEKARSKI:
Okay.
something like this using the
various Android Things and from
other services that Google
provides.     The first step is
we can use connections.
So Nearby connections is great
that
nearby devices and it
establishes an channel.
Under the hood it uses
Bluetooth, BLE,
spots, it uses whatever is
available to it at the time.
other nice thing is it provides
a short
both sides that you can display
on screens.
used devices where it shows a
little that's great in most
cases.
washing machine doesn't have a
screen on it.     So we don't
have quite enough we're going to
talk about how to address that
in a minute.Nearby connections
is the first building use.
If we look at code snippets,
these are
version of a nearby connection
sample.
nearby connections client at the
top.options.
We use the default value of
P2P_Cluster.
matter so much what we use here.
process, we need to have a
service ID.
TensorWash.  That's our
product's ID.
apple or Android.  They call it
a service ID.
what your device is, whatever
you want to call it.
endpoint discovery callback.
code whenever a new device is
discovered.
view and UI that updates showing
we want
more than one device being
available at a time.selects the
one they want, they can pick it.
establish a connection.
On the device side Nearby
supports
method where you basically
provide a device.  Then you put
the same service ID in
some callbacks that will be
called established.
So when the user has selected
the
it on the screen, now we need to
use the method which will
establish the
that's parsed in.  There are
callbacks there on
initiated is used when the
connection is
and it fills in an
authentication token we
mentioned.
So Nearby connections gives you
a value.  Once again, we don't
have a display.that in a minute.
The code is simple to work with
in
connections and it gets us going
quite quickly.about attestation
and verifying the device.sure
that the device in front of us
is connecting to.  What we do on
the phone is we actually what's
called a random challenge.
unique just for this connection.
device.
Appeared we use this to prevent
replay attacks.
takes the challenge and combines
with
and brings them together and
uses this
the Android Keystore with the
attestation certificate chain.
This certificate chain is then
sent
the phone can then check it
which we'll talk about in a
minute.Even though we're using a
random
Nearby is important because it
binds it channel we're using
right now.
limit failed connections.
constantly trying random codes
and generate some keys.
to limit that to prevent people
from attacking your device.Here
is some of the code.  Don't
worry about it too much.want to
show you bits and pieces of what
there is.
device we have the
authentication token from
Nearby.the random challenge we
had earlier.  We combine it
together.We use this code to
generate the sign-in key here.
interesting part about when you
generate
Keystore is it's done in a
trusted execution environment.
don't actually keep the key in
our app execution environment.
And this is nice because it
means
our app, they don't have the
ability to
That adds extra security to what
we're doing.this stuff.  The
purple values are standard
constants.worry about capturing
this exactly.has all of this in
it.  But I want to walk you
through a bit it.
But at the end you end up with
-- you certificate chain.  And
that is what you then pass back
to phone for it to check it and
do whatever it's going to do.
So Darren mentioned earlier the
certificate chain.
So the factory provisioned
attest agdz also comes with a
certificate chain from
back to the Android Things root
certificate.
full chain -- right at the boor.
TensorWash is now generated it's
attestation key and sent the
chain back to the phone.needs to
verify that this is a untampered
with and also the one in front
of us.
It has a number of steps and
something in a library in the
future.
verify that the certificate
chain is verify that the root is
the trusted root from Android
Things.You need to verify that
it's your product ID.
128-bit UI ID for the device.
you can take and print on the
box with a can verify that
they've matched it up of them.
You can verify the boot status,
it's sent over with a flag
indicating in tampered with.
You verify the attest identities
challenge.end up with a public
key that you can
handy when we want to
authenticate with Cloud IoT
later on.     On the phone side
we need to verify challenge is
correct.
certificate and then we create a
hash of
token from near and the random
challengehash and checks that it
matches what came from the
device.
verifies that this whole loop is
secure.we never actually sent
the   It was done by Nearby.
is done right and no man in the
middle the way.     So now we
know that the device is ours.
that helps to sort of deal with
all identified.  So now the
phone has verified it can
TensorWash.  Now we need to
authorize the device on network.
The quickest way is to pop up an
phone and say what's the Wi-Fi
SSID and passphrase.
user friendly and requires the
to put
what's being sent over to the
device is seen through the app.
The next thing you do is on the
device
the WiFiManager to set the SSID
and passphrase.
a little code snippet that does
it.
more complicated.
the WiFiManager.  This is
something we want to make that
use a small code library you can
use so that kind of code.  We
have more good news in that we
have
API called Nearby setup that's
coming to Google Play Services.
The great thing about Nearby
setup which
has the ability to take the
Wi-Fi
phone and pass them to another
device's Google Play Services.So
Android Things supports Google
Play Services.
the credentials over without
having to yourself, the user
doesn't need to type them.for
user convenience.  This is
coming soon and the details
going to be on developers
Google.com/Nearby when that's
later.We have Internet access on
our device and a key.
about how we're going to get
Cloud device.  We're going to
talk about Firebase and Cloud
IoT.     The first thing we need
to do on set up Firebase.  It's
great because it works on and
with web.
It can be on many different
devices.to use that on both the
phone and the device.
user to authenticate what with
their user name and password.
Pop up a dialogue box and we get
a token
encrypted pipe.  We can see at
the top we're doing the
requests.     It's interesting
because we're only the email ID.
We don't want to have full
Google
access to their files or email
or something like that.just
asking for their identification
details.
trying to limit scope like what
Darren talked about earlier.
end up getting a JSON web token
which we
which allows our device to
interact with Firebase as well.
ship that token, the previous
token off
log in to Firebase and do things
with that.
So on the other side we take the
Firebase and authenticate with
that.
access to the Firebase realtime
database.
looks very similar on the device
as well.
Things device is regular
Android, we use we do on the
phone.
We get a credential, pass it in
to auth.  We have a
bidirectional authentication
can fully participate with the
Firebase realtime database.
Let's switch gears to finish up.
IoT Core.
Imagine you're running a lawned
malt
machines in thawses of
locations.
these devices to Cloud IoT for
analysis.register the devices.
You have an app with
credentials.take that public
certificate that we
to Cloud IoT so it knows the
device and can trust it.
then MQTT to send requests to
Cloud IoT
signed with our key.
legitimate by verifying this key
and received earlier.
Then we send the MQTT request
using
we use TLS so that our device
knows it sending data to.
Remember, both sides need to
check the other side.     Here's
a quick snippet that shows
project IDs and things like
that.
soon that introduces how to do
Cloud IoT Core.
bottom takes any binary blob you
want worry about generating any
of the mentals.about Cloud IoT
and Firebase.can do?     We also
have Smart Home which is a
you have light bulbs you can say
dim the
If you implement Smart Home you
can say
machine, it will kick it off
with Google Assistant.
device can be enabled with the
Google Assistant.
can enable the stk into your
device
the washing machine and give it
direct directly which is kind of
cool.     So what's next?  We
have a factory key provisioning
coming soon where basically a
hardware you add keys to Android
Things devices.yourself or when
they're being produced.
is going to get on to the
device.
you won't be able to test the
key won't have an official key
from Android Things.to be
releasing the tools to be able
to do this soon.
Nearby setup API is going to be
coming soon as well.
make provisioning these things
really easy.
In summary go vision us on
Google.com.
community where you can find out
more
site where you can keep track of
what's us on social media.  If
you haven't had a chance, get
one of the IMX7 developer kits
that I/O.  Make sure you get one
of those so you Things yourself.
making production devices.
That's it for us.for coming and
we'll see you at the conference.
Thank you.
(Applause)
session.
will assist through designated
exits.
those registered for the next
room.
clear the room and return via
the registration line outside.
Thank you.
***
>> KRISTIN GRAY: Hi, and
welcome products with Android
Things.  I'm Kristin.
Android things.
I'm the for -- you can think of
it
design 101 for those who are not
skiners.
designer, we've got you covered.
In this talk we'll cover how you
can the product creation process
using Android Things.
about design framework that you
can use
you think about who your users
are and
prominent role in crafting the
products that you're creating.
We'll also talk about a concept
project
demonstrate how we've applied
the design
Android Things to create better
products. >> KRISTIN GRAY:
Thanks, Michael.
hardware design is a long and
difficult process.
anywhere from 2 to 5 years to
bring a product.  You start with
ideation.prototype phase.  Then
you choose your hardware.
design your software and get
that coded to a factory.
You finally get it on a store
shelf have to cycle back and go
through updates.
that's rapidly changing and
technology of your production
process.  How can the design
process keep up?
That's one of the main reasons
we've created Android Things.
enables people to be part of the
all the way through maintenance.
So at the heart of Android
Things
a SOM or a system on-on-module.
The SOM can be used for
prototyping
also be placed on a custom
board.
use it on your own custom PCB
board,
everything that surrounds it is
an accessory.
Ethernet to power to the head
phone jack
powerful tool for prototyping
because
the tools you need to get
connected.
different peripheral, you can
connect it breadboard and
resisters.
>> MICHAEL DELGAUDIO: So
Android
tools for you to get started
easily.
IMX7 board, a touch screen, and
a stand.
have gotten your kit or been to
the
acceptableses into a stand that
you can prototype on your desk.
In addition to the kit we offer
the
that gets you on Wi-Fi easily.
Android con for example was
provisioning Wi-Fi network was
difficult.
it on to Wi-Fi in a breeze.
process of making sure that your
can upload to see what the
Android
the TensorFlow demonstrations
before you
In addition to the tool kit app
and
we also recently updated the
Android
Now we offer code snippets,
samples, projects from the
community.
you can submit it and we'll
feature it on the site the.
We update the site so if you
make a to use, we can have that
on the site as well.
gotten your kit, head over to
the I/O >> KRISTIN GRAY:
Thanks.
end to end solution.
production like Michael
mentioned.
selection easier so you can use
the same you do production.
For prototyping, the kit offers
such as displays, a rainbow hat
and
antenna to connect the device to
Wi-Fi.
An app also makes this easier to
assemble your hardware.
It helps you get familiar with
your connect to Wi-Fi.  Finally
when you're ready for
developer console can help you
create
firm aware and release those
builds to devices.
>> MICHAEL DELGAUDIO: Great.
a concept called Lantern.
to help you understand how we
were able
bring products to life.
So Lantern is not a Google
product
we worked on with the Nord group
that anywhere around you.
You can see this as an easy to
example of how we were exploring
creativity through prototyping
It's created using off the shelf
parts.that was really important
because we
a recipe that you could
potentially build one on your
own.     So what is augmented
reality?term, AR.  There's the
AR kit.
of augmented reality using
Android Things?     So using
Lantern and Android
on to everyday objects
interesting
content that may be trapped
inside the
that may enhance the world
around us.
here the currently playing Cast
song speaker.  None of this was
done using after effectings.
all using the projection system
in the prototype we created.
Another example of how we're
augmented
this example a clock.
clock with Lantern to project
the the clock.  Again, this is
all real.
using the Lantern.
As an exploration, we felt it
because it was on this nice
round curved ticker tape look.
We're excited about theses.
share with you to demonstrate
not only
we'll get into but to give it to
the
guys may want to create with it.
So what is Lantern made of?
created using off the shelf.
Pi running are Android Things.
there are two pieces of hardware
-- two Things runs on.
the IMX boards that are in the
kit.
little more prevalent at this
point in the maker community.
felt with the HTMI output
because we can the laser
projector.  Once it's assembled,
it looks like this.You may have
seen it at the IoT dome.there as
an example.     We really
believe that this is only
the democratization of design
hardware
access to these kinds of tools
we're talking about today.
was really difficult in the past
say to
this and acceptable it into a
hardware
was expensive and tools like
Android
readily available for you to
access to prototypes.
So Lantern can also be assigned
context.  So it's aware of its
orientation.
accelerometer in Lantern we can
change
project different content on to
different surfaces.
wanted a star chart on the
ceiling or in
you could see the calendar
information projected to the
wall.
This code is available today at
GitHub.
Lantern.  If you want to
download the source own.
So we didn't set out to create
Lantern.Lantern come from?  You
can see a number of sketches
that created.
If you're designers, you may be
sketching we started prototyping
using Android Things.
design to turn our idea into a
real
share with you the process that
we went
frameworks that we used to
create too.
>> KRISTIN GRAY: Thank you.
design helps create better
products.
raise of hand have created
something person?  Go ahead and
raise your hands.  That's
awesome.when we design things,
you might know principles to
ground our work.
design can be carried over from
software
banking company, for instance,
to a instance.
So we use these processes and
work, but then we use the design
process
And then we continue iterating.
we're taking some of the
software UI applying them to
hardware.
So what is design?
people in a context to help them
achieve a goal.are familiar with
the development to a user story.
So, for example, as a dog owner,
I connect a dog feeder so I can
feed my
person who orders pizza -- I
order pizza
visibility into the delivery
route so I arrive.
Such as a simple as a knight I
want a I can defeat .dragon.
stronger sword.  This is the
tool that the sword uses
goal to achieve in defeating the
dragon.interface.  People think
of a user interface as a
or a mobile phone or a tablet
because and things happen,
right?  It's magic.     While
this is true, user interface
that.  In the example before,
the user interface is the sword.
But we can see here from this
slide that
build upon an interface to
create a joy
to create a game that shoots
down aliens from the sky.there
could be feedback on top of that
heeds inside of a breadboard
that light button.  So all of
these are an example of a user
interface.One of the most simple
user interfaces
things is simple as a piece of
paper and a pen.
And admittedly a design is
iterative.
like the ma'am ster in the
wheel.done.  Teams need to learn
through the and iteration.  That
being said, Android Things
iterate faster by allowing you
to work
issues by using the design kit
as a base
phase and allowing for early
Over the
developer console. >>
MICHAEL DELGAUDIO:  So design is
used to create better products
for everyone.
design is agnostic of medium,
time,
We believe it's important to
think process that's agnostic of
these things
changes, you have the right
tools to
whatever problem you're working
on.
So we talked about design being
in
people in the context of goals.
look like?
So each milestone owled here,
make less mistakes, produce
better production process along
the way.
product needs to take shape as
it's evolving.you make decisions
sooner.
So thinking about planning.
First we aim to create baseline
that may exist for our users.
about pain points from other
people or ourselves.
at competitive products to see
how
how we might want to do it
differently.
software systems, you may be
familiar
personas and gain empathy into
the mind
product.  We create things like
wire frames,
the story how we've seen the
product use unfolding over time.
We then create something.
hypothesis of how something
should work,
medium fidelity designs so we
saw those preliminary skechls.
may create something like a
video
it might look and feeltches.how
it might look and feel before it
actually worksmake something on
a breadboard to get an
do or what some pft key
characters of
look like.
It's important to get feedback
in this we need to understand
how people are actually using
things.
equal active feedback and
understanding
how they feel about a particular
feature
proposing.  Quantitative to
understand how being used or not
used.
sharing projects with each other
other people.  It's really
helpful to get an something so
that that person can point may
not have seen.
Guerilla research, I'm shog your
familiar with the project can
give you because then you can
have an objective
you may be creating from
somebody who the project before.
Finally, in later stages you may
lab story to ask participants to
use
a controlled environment side by
side may be like.     And we're
not saying that you need
things along the way.
storyboard which translates into
a click internal feedback and
iterate on that cycle.
we may do a bit of competitive
analysis
requirements and create a looks
like
perform some Guerilla research
for
with the product we're creating.
>> KRISTIN GRAY: Something else
to
hardware isn't hard bullet it's
different.what parts you need to
make what you want.
think about designing a system
possibly
Sometimes it's like Jenga, one
another.
You need to think about
futureproofing.
space do you need to allocate
for user you're designing a
camera?
This might be importantly for
users.You need to think about
form factor.
want to fit into your design fit
into a delightful for your
users?
One other thing to consider is
your interaction design.
when you connect the product to
the
companion app for that?
notifications can be seen from a
reasonable view?make it
accessible?
Do you tell the user at 8:00
a.m.
actually using your product or
do you wait until 2:00 a.m.
people might not be using your
product and they might be
asleep.     Also, what if
there's no screen?consider for
the land of IoT.
process using Android Things to
help us
back -- get that feedback
sooner, make
for these questions and also
ultimately products.
And one thing to note, if you're
a something that you're really
familiar with is the undo
button.
In hardware, you don't have an
undo button.
roll back a release when you're
a software engineer as well.
When you're designing for
hardware, it's more permanent.
need a strong iteration cycle.
forward in your design cycle,
the more
backwards.
For example, in 1966 NASA's
budget was over 4% of the U.S.
spending and the undertaking was
mammoth.
can shoot 3D printers into
space,
there, update it from your
laptop and fraction of the
price.
because it's fun and because we
can.
One other thing to note here is
+th design process.
with the mercury, Gemini and
Apollo get us to the moon.
Mercury put a man into space.
extend the capsule stay from
hours to us to the moon.
These were some pretty big
iteration you know they were
really on to something.
You may notice even today some a
water fall process.  It requires
everything to be perfect
is expensive in end-to end
cycles.
the requirements and hand those
off once
designers who finish the designs
and engineers for
implementation.
off, then they hand it off to
the QA back through a
maintenance cycle and you again.
If you make a mistake or decide
you
you're late in the process, you
have to
to the requirements section.
On the right you'll see
something
like the process that Mike was
talking about.
more milestones sprinkled in
there.
iteration cycle.  You plan,
prototype, feedback, and
iterate.You keep doing that
throughout your process.
flexible and helps keep costs
contained in the process.
In the past there were also very
contribute to the creation of a
project engineers.
Now with access to tools like on
demand 3D printing.Anyone can
print 3D parts.
now with the ease of prototyping
tools.
their skills to hardware and
Android do so.     Specifically
dealing with software,
labor intensive to create and
release a build.
to set up testing environments
for those devices as well.
Android Things we've introduced
the
open up the dev console and
create a
a few easy steps. >> MICHAEL
DELGAUDIO:  Now that he
little bit about design and
process, we
to the Lantern project I
mentioned earlier.use the
process of planning,
iterating to help us improve
this concept?
think about people, context and
goals idea.
As a designer I like to bring my
plontionor projection.happened
next?
We began to create a looks like
feels prototype.
Before we were even acceptabling
together the housing, we started
to
time rendering look like as a
projects
me.  What would I want to
project on the I was typing?
Would it be some bit coin
information
of something else or how I'm
doing in a certain game?
like feels like prototype helps
you
exists in its end state without
actually
through the full creation
process.     Again, we went back
to sketching to housing may come
together.
thinking about the parts that
needed to
earlier, we need the Raspberry
Pi board,
and start to fit inside of this
specific shape.     This was one
of the first
foam core and some of the parts.
needed, we began to put them
together
into a #3d print right away but
using
cutting them out and making the
form so into the lamp.
Before we put everything
together,
simulations may look like
functionally.
seeing is Ancell rorment test
showing content based on
orientation.  It's really
simple.
projector, the Raspberry Pi
connected to Android Things.  We
just said, can we show you the
show us the direction of which
way the object is pointing.
it know if it's pointing up,
down, or sideways.right-hand
side these are initial tests
could get the currently playing
song off
projecting it on to note pad to
see if
using the hardware we think we
want to use.     In looking at
physical prototyping,
first
assembled changing the content
based on the physical prototype.
Here he flips up at the ceiling.
can see the content starts to
come to life.
together into their final form.
So one tool that I wanted to
highly beneficial in creating
this project was processing.
if you're a designer, you may
already be
processing as a light wait IDE
that create visual sedations.
because I can create visual
sedations
a nice library that was released
from
called processing for Android.
processing and test that on
Android device.
your phone and your wear device.
Things which is really nice
because you
visualualization and load that
on your You can work with the
visual sedations
and then integrate them into the
hardware.
from processing, you can export
Android
you'll need to upgrade the SDK.
slightly Android build number.
Once you do that, you'll be able
to
visual wall sedations to
manipulate them
GPIO inputs.
So thinking about our iterative
about getting feedback on
Lantern.
members around us to use it.
because this was a private thing
we were working on.
the project.
Things thought it was
interesting.
from was the idea of integrating
our first iteration of the
project.
adverse incorporating
interactivity
we could project content in
darve fer different ways.
Interactivity added another
layer of complexity.
basic form so we could prove the
working.  However, when we
shared the prototype
they were keen on integrating a
camera.
So because we were working with
with 3D printings, we were able
to make the camera.  The Nord
team happened to be working in
London.
And the Mountain View team was
over here.
story how this evolved because,
again,
access to tools like this like
3D printing from the web.were
able to actually build
prototypes
collaborate them and build them
up really cool.  Android Things
made it really easy to new
hardware like this and connect
it to
pieces in a snap.  With the
camera in place we had a
range of interactivity and
interactive
kwau Quick, Draw.
You may have seen kwaub which is
a labs project from Google that
prompts you with a word.
draw it on the tablet on the web
or on
guess what you're drawing.
in a physical world now we had
this projected AR system.
So what we did is we did just
that.
limited to screen-based inputs.
cool if we could just use a pen,
paper,
that into the Quick, Draw engine
and
that you could use in rt
physical world.
the demonstration that we had
set up over in the IoT dome.
you haven't visited the dome,
you can out for yourself.  We
have a Lantern set up and it
works great.
You're prompted with a word and
as
the pen and paper, it starts to
guess on in front of you.
Think of this as a mixed reality
surface.
There you go.
So now we've gone one -- through
one cycle, right?
planned, we've prototyped and we
have some improvements. >>
KRISTIN GRAY:  No, no, no.
product yet.
So what we're going to do is
start the
process
maybe mass producing something
like Lantern.
So Android Things has many
started.  After you've completed
your proof of initial
prototypes, everything is
want to look like and move over
to awes because of the SOM, like
I mentioned before.
to re-do all the work you did in
the
because you're using the same
products.     Say I want to mass
produce Lantern, right.
feedback process I wanted to
learn more
and processes, so I visited a
few factories in China.
turns out, they have a process
too and product design process.
factory will build out a line
with stations.
stacked with people who put
together the product.
millions of Lantern,the factory
might
make cool robots and automate
things.
product designer to continue
iterating
probably leaning more towards
software changes and I'll show
you why.
( So you've created ten units
phase, right.  Then you send
those off to the factory.they're
going to run everything through
validation test.
And you start out with
engineering
You send your prototypes to the
back maybe a hundred units.sure
that everything works with the
the.  They're probably going to
be using
hard tools in this stage to
create all industrial design.
And then after that, after
you've
you send any feedback back to
the factory.
design validation tests.tooling.
All. Stations are set up and
stacked with people.this point
the product design team
Things Console to update
software and
chance s chabls s channels to
help your better.  In the
meantime you should be user
these phases.  Once you have
feedback from the
send things back, then you move
into the      This phase makes
sure that possible.  This is
more for the factory than you.
you back about a thousand units.
test metrics and then for mass
the developer console to send
updates if
metrics on these devices.     As
you can see here, as you move
should be sending devices back
to youle
should be testing those and
giving feedback through QA.move
forward through this framework
your
get more creative, more
MacGyvery and
because it might be too
expensive to again in you're
working with a product team.
Some of the tools you can use to
smoother is the developer
console.
library which allows you to --
it allows
app library and use them on
multiple projects.
multiple Lanterns you can write
one APK
each of your different products.
When you're ready to test Over
the
create releases and channels.
can actually go through and use
the --
settings and create a build
individually
the steps to set each of the
firm aware
device and create a build very
seamlessly.
When you're ready to test Over
the create releases and
channels.
channels so you can test your
softwares detailed testing.
channel and an update and push
these
devices wirelessly.
Finally, after your release, you
you gather equal active data on
your
better decisions on what to do
next.
version 0.1 maybe you have a set
of features you
you want to move and add Quick,
Draw you
by using the build tool and
check in doing better.
Once your device is on the
market, stop there.  You should
be gathering feedback doing and
checking everything as your
device
any updates you've created,
continue
gorilla testing and anything in
that
continue to do to help create
updates
you define the next iteration
cycles through your thing.
So we've taken you through
Android Things kits, making
final
builds and hardware bringup, the
factory
the end product with maintenance
and
iterations each step of the way.
>> MICHAEL DELGAUDIO: Thanks,
Kristin.
about today how design is people
in context with goals.it's a
process.
We can plan, prototype,
feedback, and on that process in
order to help those
achieve those goals.  Now it's
easier than ever to in the
creation of physical products
before.  Android Things offers
tools to help prototyping
process that you can use ideas.
Processing enables the fast
graphics and combined with
hardware powerful experiences.
make better connected products
for
You can get started today at
experiments.with Google.with
Lantern.  You can check out the
samples at with Google.com.
If you picked up a kit today
there's sample code there for
you to try out.
kit you can get one over at the
IoT dome.
the Nord group, Ben, Joe, Mike
and the
interconstant neantle
prototyping for this.
yes and making the ML magic come
to life.  Come check it out.We
would love to see you over
there.  Thank you guys for
coming.If you have feedback, we
do want to hear from you.
(Applause).
>> Thank you for joining this
session.will assist with
directing you through the
designated exits.
We'll be making room for those
who
room, we ask that you clear the
room and registration line
outside.  Thank you.
Android Things.  Glad you're
still with us.manager here.
>> AMY JANG: I'm Amy and I lead
on Console. >> ADAM
RODRIGUEZ:  We're going to
our devices in the field.
platform for building you some
IoT.
more than one of something, how
do you its lifetime.
How do you protect those
devices?we're here to talk about
today.
is Android Things and why you
might want it?
of Android developed with the
same tools you know and love.
This is Android after all so
it's easy.prototype to
production.
engineer to do this.  We have
full so many as.
you need to use Android Things
SOMMings.for the platform.
You need the right Android code.
need low level firm aware to
drive that hardware.
updates security it built in.
security of your device.
fixes that you can implement
throughout product.     Our goal
with Android Things is to
you, easy, managed, and secure.
why is IoT so hard?
Think about what it would take
for you
managed secure IoT devices.
building the devices, designing
the
It's hard but it's also the
special your device unique.
Beyond that, there's a ton of
other you have to do.  If you
want your devices to be secure,
to keep up to date with latest
security
found those patches, you have to
build a patches.
If the update goes bad, how do I
make break your customer's
devices?
upday-to-days A/B, partitions,
channel management.
you need for successful IoT but
massive job.
Our goal is to make it easier
for you with Android Things.The
hardware and software design is
should be.  We make it easier
because you can use
tools such as Android Studio to
do it.
with firm aware code because of
the SOM model.
comes to security updates, you
get to
here to find and fix security
holings.
you get security patches with
literally you years after you
ship your last device.
leveraging the same technology
used to devices every day.
differentiates your product, the
>> AMY JANG: Let's walk through
an example.
Adam and I are building a
laundry folding robot.
folding socks, right?
Learning which is a perfect use
case for Android Things.I take
it from a prototype that I built
available for everyone?
comes in.
market.  You can use the console
to take care of all your needs.
First in configure, you define a
called products.
Uploading apps like editor in
studio,
manage your apps using library
and console.
you can secure images with apps
you just wrote.
seamless updates to your devices
and use your device went out
smoothly.
works. >> ADAM RODRIGUEZ:
The first step
the console about the product
you plan to build.
configure our laundry robot.
create models.
Maybe we have a UK skew and a US
skew.are in different versions.
You want to pick your SOM type.
Pick a SOM on the features you
need and to hit.  Picking a SOM
is important because it
about the mij you want to
create.
to change it, it's really easy
without
I really love that about the
manage SOM model.
downgrade when you want to cut
costs at
something really cheap and then
you can powerful SOM.     Set up
product sharing too.
together, we build it through
the
create apps and builds.  The
next step is to write apps.
Android Things is no exception.
functionality inside of Android
Things.
feature of socks she wrote in
SoCs APK.
Play Services, Firebase, it
always works
Android after all.
can add them into builds.
break out our laundry robot's
functionality.
When you have a new version of
the takes care to show you the
most recent one.     One piece I
really love about this is app
sharing.like you can share a
product with a clob apps too.
Android is about building apps
that
and Android Things is no
exception here either.
with your team or other people
building similar products.
You'll probably only use apps
you built yourself.
you're using with other
utilities and common features.
>> AMY JANG: Now it's time to
apps you just built.
functionality.
Adam uploaded in the app console
and me.
It's time to pick it up on a to
build devices.
Build everything comes together,
apps,
configurations you want to add.
are called build configurations
which
rules and configuration that
specify the
By device image I mean the
images to
devices an images to create Over
the Air update.     In this
build step you can create
configurations and manage them.
For most of you you have just
I/O the developer kit.
starter kit settings.
prepopulated for you.  For this
example, let's walk through
example from starting from
scratch.     First, one of the
most important
Android Things version.
comfortable with because those
will have and security ups.
You're not forced to use the
latest it's recommended for this
reason.     Next step in this
step you will see
you have uploaded in the app lib
riff.to include in your build.
provided by Google like Google
Play Services.want Google Play
Services?
advantage of the latest Google
API such
Firebase, including the new ML
kit
Simply click on the checkbox you
saw dialogue and it will be
included in your build. >>
ADAM RODRIGUEZ:  Back to the
build.
your apps, take a look at the
requesting and make sure you are
okay with them.
users can opt with security
themselves for them.  If you're
only using apps, there surprises
but if you're using from
This is helpful from preventing
the
something wrong you weren't
expecting measure.  It won't be
surprising to see other
other IoT with shared apps so
looking at important.     The
next step is about adding your
build.
If your device has a display,
you can
like here.
You can add your own custom
animation.if you want to choose
fonts.
displays we don't want to burden
them with fonts.
about radio reducing the image
size with products.     Now your
Android Things device if it was
just the SOM.  Hardware
configuration is where you
peripherals and control our
feed.
hard kwar config.configurations
differently.
it.     While this tool is
currently
This is where you configure all
your
such as cameras, displays and
speakers.over our I/O.  You can
do pinmuxing and determine
attached to which functions.
more updates soon. >> AMY
JANG:  Here you are in your
final build step.You'll see that
the configurations you
their total estimated sizes
under OEM partition.
estimated size in summary and
set the partition as you like.
You may wonder what are these
a developer change and which
partitions the Air update?
On the left is a sample
partition
the one you got in the developer
kit.
differences between the SoC
vendors and
through the partitions used by
core and the same across all
SOMs.  Starting with system.
boot are read-only partitions.
Android Things platform.
Boot is for kernel and system is
where
Vbmeta is a read-only partition
and mechanism.
As the name suggests this is
where written too.
It's a hash written by Google
using a
system and vendor and signed
with a secure key stored in
Google.
For every boot sequence of a
device
code is authentic and no known
security using this information.
has been found.  So you don't
want to mess around with
partition.     Vendor is a
read-only partition as well.
the binary image from SoC
vendors are
driver libraries specific to SoC
are usually put in here.
OEM and OEM bootloader are
developers and that's you.
it's been generated, it cannot
be like I just talked about.
contents of the build
configuration that console is
written to.
Android Things developers
through a console.
is also generating new when
you're
configuration for the OTA OEM
bootloader is where the
configuration you have schosen
that build is written too.
If you're Android developer, you
this partition, user data.
write their user data at run
time.
you install through APK install
or the
Studio are also written into
this partition.
question.
Add package name a unique Ofer
of the app.
exists in both user data and OEM
how
manager know which app to be
used?
been generated so the APKs
already is.  When you're
developing and you're most
changing your APKs via ATP
install.
flow, the APKs in user data is
always
So what this means is if you
have OEM, you want the APK
loaded in OEM to
Misc is another read-only
partition used by platform.
for miscellaneous needs like
bootloader functionalities.
Factory and its bootloader
per device configurations like
serial
factor factory.  This partition
is writable by
factory and going oh be
read-only offer it's shipped.
to this partition requires
special tools will provide for
you.     So up to now we've gone
over all
Android Things that core
architecture uses.
noticed the partitions in this
table are sections A and B.
This is where the OTA, Over the
Air comes in.
It works by A/B partition
mechanism
exists in two duplicate memory
spaces.
use to users where devices can
still be
partition where the updates are
being in the inactive partitions
A/B.
the rebooting with the secure
boot
up to the partition where the
update has been installed on to.
It's also important to note that
Things partitions is fixed at a
certain size.
board memory is also fixed.
remaining fixered memory to be
split
user data partition.
between the two.     So let's
walk through an example.
LTS OS a couple apps, Google
Play
hardware configuration.
final build step, with he took
away the that we've seen so far.
If you haven't been paying
attention last slides, it's
okay.  All you need to know is
that the
partition is fixed size so that
the OEM
ask you to input is going to be
a size
So what this means is when you
partition by 100, the user data
200.
So here's the most important
you should take away interest
this talk.
partition size is important when
you're
When devices are baked with the
chosen
fixed in the size layout until
they are reflashed.
because of the nature of A/B and
the OTA talked about.
So these devices only receive
OTA build with the same
partition size.
when setting the size is to
leave some growth.
You may want to add more
functionality to your APK.
You may want to add new cool
boot more memory.
So plan for future and estimate
how
want between apps growth versus
the data growth.
Again, you don't have to panic
yet.
prototyping and development
phase, you
fining the right size because
you can reflash the device.
need to estimate and finalize
when images.
You now you've chosen the right
size build.  You can choose
between two image and
production.
capabilities like ADB and
production
used by end users.  It doesn't
provide the bugging.devices are
flashed with production
tampered for security reason so
it needs order to make it
debugable.
image will be generated and the
download browser.
Now you have download the image
file.
from the file to my devices,
right?
tool to make it super simple and
easy for you.
to the tool section and download
the instruction no, sir the
script.
straightforward and your devices
will be ready to go.
use fastboot mode instead of the
script if you so wish.
that we're finished building,
Android Things device. >>
ADAM RODRIGUEZ:  Up until this
building functionality into your
Android Things device.Android
Things makes development easy,
done the same thing with a bunch
of there.  Release is where
things get really different.
supporting, pushing new
features, not to
Things starts to shine.
with it and you're familiar with
it or
First off, use channels to break
up population.  You have a few
owned by testers and
them all getting the same
builds.
segment them logically.
for people who like blue to
further divide things.
channels you can do what you
want, if
is a reference to the Canary in
the coal mine Id yom.
there's anything wrong with the
new
will tell you about it first.
plenty of bugs.  Beta is for
your teb testers.
who are okay with new
functionality and related
software.
everything should work.
it to be.  In developer previews
we got lots of
people wanted lots of channels
to divide in different ways.
created custom channels for
them.     All right.  Now that
you have these channels, how get
your devices on to the channels
in the first place?default to
the stable channel.
channel, you can set it via the
API or
through ADB as shown up here.
remember how Amy talked about
release versus develop images.
You can flash a device to a new
channel
develop image.  You can't change
the channel either.
to prevent unwanted malicious
code on your devices.     Okay.
Now that you've assigned the
channels updates to them.  You
take the builds we created
earlier.Create updates from them
and get them devices.  Updates
are basically builds with new
fixes or changes.
or an Over the Air update.
into the B partition.
partition.  However if there's a
problem, it A partition.  I love
this.
instant and fault tolerant too.
Things takes advantage of this.
Rather than pushing an update up
to
you can role it on gradually
you're not the same time.
We recommend it to derisk your
updates.all of this technology
is using the same
every day to update millions of
devices
updates, fractional updates.
but crucially important if you
want updates world-wide. >>
AMY JANG:  Android Things
architecture that Google uses.
work.  You might be wondering
how does the the hood?  When you
specify through Android update
the OTA server to hold
your update channel.
The devices will report to the
OTA
information every five hour
interval.
let the devices know that you
have an update to pick it up.
Devices download and install the
inactive A/B partition that we
talked about.
be able to use the devices while
this -- during this process.
Using Update Manager API, you
have full
policies such as hauven do you
want your
update check and customize
update behavior by link to
events.
Let's go through a set of events
device and the following updates
posted to that app listener.
Update engine will check OTA to
the
will let the client know there's
a new update to pick it up.
will start the downloading the
update.flow diagram, the
corresponding update
listener and that's your app.
set, your app can trigger reboot
of the it's appropriate.  When
the device boots up, it will the
new partition where the update
is written to.
Upon reboot it checks for update
already updated it sits back at
the idle update check happens.
policy.  You can grap the Update
Manager policy you like.
Using apply only policy Update
Manager
download and install the update
whenever available.  You can the
change the update API say two
days for example.
But say you want to control the
whole flow.
use the check only policy to
listen to
control the whole update
process.
available status, you can decide
whether
start the download and install
and when
time, you can trigger the
perform update it.
When complete, you will get the
and also when you think it's a
good devices to reboot.  It's
all again under your control.
It's very possible that your day
update.
When a customer buys a product
after
time, you might have already
upgraded next coolest thing.
You want them to start with
that, right?You don't want users
to download a
software before they can start
using your product.
updates mean this pay load
update is as small as possible.
Basically based on your factory
image
OTA pushes Android Things
Console will
between their current build and
your new coolest thing.that your
friend was unwrapping a
have to wait 20 minutes to
download the latest version?
terrible experience, right?
better. >> ADAM RODRIGUEZ:
At this point bit of time
talking about security.
simply build a secure device.
and updating and looking for
but maybe we get different jobs
and then what?
about a new vulnerability do we
research kernel library fixes?
Maybe we get with the engineers
and push it to our users?  No.
That's not what happens.
live on connected to the internt
perhaps
vulnerable.
Thankly we have a solution to
this.
SOM strategy Google can
confidently push
IoT devices running that SOM be
it a web cam.  Flip this flag on
your channel and all
get regular updates from Google
with zero involvement from you.
It's important to note you're
not required to flip this flag.
If you don't enable auto updates
you can
want to manage them.yourself.
Let's talk about how Android
Things works.  Major versions on
Android Things releases in
normal Android.
over the long term and represent
Android API framework changes.
The auto update flag on their
channel major versions.
If you start on major version 1
even
version 2 is released, you get
security 1 if you so choose.
The minor version are low risk
updates.They don't have
framework changes but API
additions.
If you flip the auto update
flag, you
to get updates on major versions
if you start at 1.
next minor version rolls out you
will migrate to 1.3.see these
approximately every month.
and these updates auto update
with the auto update.
updates through Google we expect
you to
across every minor version and
security patch.up to you.
You can flip the auto update
flag or yourself.  It's our goal
to make it the easiest there.
Over the lifetime of your
product.
work across SOMs and major
versions and years?     Each SOM
is supported by Google for years
from the time it was first made
available major version.
and start building on major
version 1
the next three years while
remaining on version 1.
have to update to major version
2 to get the full support time.
Of course devices will need much
longer than three years.
can update to the next version
and get a longer support window.
You can push your own updates
your your lifetime.  Finally if
you're looking for longer
talk to us for options for
extended support. >> AMY
JANG:  All right.  We've pushed
our updates.robots can now fold
sockings.
back and monitor how our robots
are doing in the field.
might want to check how many
users are
getting the updates I just
pushed or how is my U.S.compared
to those in Korea.
solution all the way to device
analytics.
you can monitor how your devices
are doing across your product.
You can use time rates and
filter to do a deeper analysis.
can filter devices by IP
countryings and on.
Within an hour after you push
OTA
come to this monitor screen to
see how
if there are any errors and what
stage are your devices at?
the granularity that we provide
is up to every minute.
monitor update checks, various
download
finally the reboot event which
tells the the new partition.
These events that you see here
map to status events you saw in
the Update Manager API earlier.
If there were any errors with
the
the update error graph and
push my OTA I can watch this
graph to
doing well, if the release that
I pushed went out smoothly.
>> ADAM RODRIGUEZ: Okay.
update your production devices
in the
quickly about why you should
care.
that matters, the hardware ander
differentiate your product and
lean on
regular Android developers and
use Kotlin and Android Studio.
You get to take advantage of the
same
update millions of devices in
the field every day.
fractional updates A/B
partitions and enhanced
monitoring.you imagine building
all of this yourself.  I'm sure
you could.
But something tells me you would
much
functions than updating a
structure.     There are
security updates from
make sure your product stays
secure from you for years down
the road.
make it easy to build secure
updatable
there's so much opportunity for
new
>> AMY JANG: With that we want
to attending our talk on how to
update field with Android Things
Console.
are many options out there for
IoT which choose.  If you're
comfortable with writing
Android Things makes it super
easy for you to get started.
you plan to build and if you
care about
and you want easy management of
your Things will be a great
solution for you.  Thank you.
(Applause)